services and elderly Affairs committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the kobit 19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuance to
executive order 200 2004 this public
body is authorized to meet
electronically
this today will be a session of public
hearings and executive sessions
please note that there is no physical
location for the members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order I am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate a
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and that the public has access
to contemporaneous to listen
contemporaneously and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or my telephone
unnecessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and with RSA 91-k
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email H C S at
leg.state dot NH dot u s in the events
the entire public is unable to access
the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
Christina Daya is the staff assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call votes
we'll start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
his or her presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting
is required under the right to know law
with the clerk please call the roll
representative Marsh
yeah
McMahon representative McMahon present
representative Nelson
present in Brookfield and no one's with
me
representative Acton
I'm present in Fremont and I'm alone in
the house
representative gay
I'm present
representative Cushman present and in
the wrong
representative Folsom president
representative Kelsey good morning
representative Alexander here subbing
for representative Kelsey I'm here in
yellowy
thank you representative King president
at the LLP representative Cobalt
present in my home office in Wilton and
there's no one in the room with me there
are other people in the house
representative Weber
I'm here in my home in Walpole and I am
alone
Representatives snow president uh here
in my apartment in Manchester uh my wife
is also here I need to explain to people
that at some point the fire department
is coming in and they're going to be
setting off alarms which are
unbelievably loud so I'm going to have
to remain muted and vote with thumbs up
and thumbs down otherwise it'll blow you
all out of your chairs
sorry about that thank you
representative snow I'll look for your
thumb
um
yes I
I'm alone in my study and freedom my
wife is in the house we'll be going to
work later
representative Solway representative
saloway is present at his home in uh the
office in Lee New Hampshire and I am
alone in the room
I'm home alone in my uh living room in
Somersworth New Hampshire
representative
morning
um I'm here in Nashua alone in the room
but not in the house
representative Shapiro
I am here I'm in my home office in Keene
representative Woods uh good morning I'm
at home in my study I'm alone in my
study but my wife is elsewhere in the
house
representative Merchant
I'm home and my house in Claremont New
Hampshire and my wife is somewhere in
the house
representative Pearson
and we have everyone for a substitute
except representative McKay is that
correct yes thank you and when he shows
up we'll make sure to
call upon him
opening the hearing now on House Bill
relative to equal access to places of
public accommodation and the chair calls
on representative come TWA to introduce
uh thank you Mr chair good morning Mr
chair and honorable committee members
hb506 is about anti-discrimination
nobody should be discriminated against
for any reason
if it were up to me I would have one
anti-discrimination law but as we have
seen over the years we keep adding
special classes because our world keeps
changing
it is too bad we cannot have a law that
says no one can be discriminated against
for any reason ever it would solve a lot
of our problems but let's be real if we
all just practice what we learned in
kindergarten be kind give someone a
helping hand we would not need any of
these laws but that is not the case in
today's world
so today I come before you because
people are being discriminated against
harass losing their jobs tattling on
each other it is ridiculous and now we
are seeing other states talking about
implementing laws we need a car to
access public places
since when do we need a card to act as a
public place we say no discrimination
for anyone but today discrimination is
rampant and I am talking about families
turning on each other
parents turning on children children
turning on parents I have never seen
anything like it in my life I have lived
through discrimination I've seen it been
a victim of it and I understand it
I have constituents who have been denied
access to a grocery store they went to
for over 20 years because of a severe
medical condition and now we look to
another state who is talking about a
coveted passport to get into an arena a
public place
we hear terms all the time but really
show me your papers
we have the argument about requiring an
ID to vote but yet going into a public
place you will need an ID
we have people calling the police of the
AG's office not knowing that the person
may have the medical condition we're
denying access to those people from
entering food and beverage
establishments and to other public
places because of a medical condition
who are denying the owners of these
establishments the income they may
receive from them if they were allowed
access
these businesses are denying access
because they are afraid of the
government shutting them down
when we are afraid of what our
government will do to us in Jeopardy of
losing all of our liberties and Freedoms
this flies in the face of our state
motto
Live Free or Die because death is not
the worst of all evils
and yet here we are today we do not live
free people are in constant fear people
are tattling on each other talking
behind their back snickering
some people are afraid to go out in
public places because they cannot wear a
medical device or they're afraid they
will be denied access because they do
not take a mandated vaccine
public health is very important and we
need to be cognizant of that but
everybody should have a choice
we have a choice of what of religion we
have a choice of occupation we have a
choice of sexual orientation we should
not be denied access to public places
because of our choices
people should not be looking at people's
medical conditions or disabilities and
causing them psychological harm and
making them feel less than human this is
what discrimination is making someone
feel less than
the last time I checked we are all
created equal and that means everyone
you will hear that this is creating a
special class as Citizens unfortunately
it is a road we have gone down as we
keep updating our special class of
detentions and it is a shame that we
have to do this so that people are not
discriminated against so this is our
reality
it is not the way it should be but it is
the way it is it is unfortunate that
anyone discriminates against anyone for
any reason
so I please please ask you to pass this
anti-discriminant law discrimination law
so that everybody no matter who they are
or what reason they have is not
discriminated against
and thank you and I'm open for any
questions
will you take questions yes I will
anyone in the committee wishing to
uh
representative Sullivan uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Christ does this mean
that if a person comes to my store
and has not been vaccinated
and declines to wear a mask
that I cannot request that they not
enter the store so that I can protect my
employees
is your store available for Public
Access yes
then yes that would be the case because
you were denying the public you are
discriminated against those that cannot
wear a mask that have a medical
condition
the chair recognizes representative
Merchant
chairman
I'm representative salawway that's the
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
if I own a business and a child comes in
that's not well behaved and tearing the
place apart and the parent is oblivious
or could care less and they do it these
people do exist do I have a right to put
them out of the store or do I let the
child continue to be disruptive to
buying business
is what type of business is it a private
business or a public business and what I
mean by that is it open to the public
yes it is it's a grocery store okay
so
this doesn't have anything to do with
the child this has to do there are
certain things where you cannot
discriminate against somebody for
and this is just adding one of those
items
If I Were A store owner I would ask the
parent to please
get their child in check
um
and if they're destroying being
destructive to
I would assume that you could ask them
to leave but you didn't deny them access
you let them come into the store but for
other reasons for that because they were
being destructive
to your products
you ask them to leave
but this law this law has nothing to do
with that
representative Contour this is
representative Pearson in the chair
um what about something that is closer
for example the signs that say no shirts
no shoes no service
um I'm wondering if some people post
that sign because no shirt no shoes is a
health problem or are perceived as a
health hazard
um would this bill speak to that and if
not shouldn't
it does not speak to that this bill
speaks specifically to medical devices
thank you representative knurk
yes I would like to follow up on both
representative saloways and
representative Pearson's comments then
if we uh about my initial question was
the same but I'll come back if you feel
that we cannot that sort of business
that's open to the public does not have
a right to set a rule to let's say
prevent you coming in without a shirt or
shoes or let's say even start naked
where that's really more an issue of
offending people's pretty sensibilities
but you think though that they would not
have the right to set a rule that would
protect their employees health or their
own health
and if so I'm trying to understand why
so
when you deny everyone access for not
where you know your shirt shoes and um
the shirt and shoes and I'm sure all
clothing because we don't we have
decency laws in this state which I
believe that would be kind of covered
under
um but this is regarding anti is
discriminating against people with
medical conditions and disabilities you
are do they are just there's actual
follow up
follow up well wouldn't you consider
your discriminating against a person who
doesn't wish to wear clothing and if so
again why would that be any different
than discriminating I mean you could
almost like at a mask as a piece of
clothing which it isn't but it's
certainly similar and why would we have
a special treatment for that over a
like uh thank you representative for the
question but like I said uh we have
decency laws in the state and a face
mask under the FDA is considered a
medical device
so
um there are two you're talking you you
can't compare the two
and the people in the store
apparently
they're protecting themselves if they're
wearing masks and we have there's
plexiglasses there's all kinds of things
in place but you're making it so that
people cannot go to the grocery store
or they cannot go to a food
establishment you're actually
discriminating against them because they
cannot wear a medical device
foreign
recognizes representative Marsh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
and as you may be aware I'm a hospital
trustee and I felt a little concerned
how this bill might affect the ability
of my hospital to conduct its operations
am I correct that if there's still were
to become law if I had a nurse in my ICU
would happen to have tuberculosis my
hospital was up able to mandate that
that nurse be treated before she could
take care of pictures
I'm sorry you broke up at the end there
so could you please repeat your question
yes it's my Hospital
happens to have a nurse is acquired
tuberculosis
if this still works would it be true
that my Hospital could not mandate that
this nurse be treated for her
tuberculosis before she took care of
Les so let me thank you representative
let me see if I understand you said you
have a nurse with tuberculosis yes
and
she could not be treated in the ICU
she doesn't want to be treated
she doesn't want to be treated yes would
that mean that I as a hospital
administrator would not be able to keep
her from working and take care of
patients in my ICU
Les
so
I don't believe because she is an
employee of yours
I don't believe that
um
in the medical
profession I mean and this has happened
to me I actually applied for a job at a
hospital and because of the mandates
they were going to require of me I chose
to not take that job
um
so I don't know we're talking about
public access we're I'm talking about
patrons going into establishments into
public housing you're an employee you're
talking in about an employer employee
relationship
uh again this is representative Pearson
as I read this no individual
shall be denied benefits of Rights
um what about children in going to
school where there is a mandate for
certain basic vaccines my own opinion is
this can go way way too far but there
are certain basic vaccines that
virtually all school systems agree to as
I read this bill uh if a parent did not
want that the child could not be denied
so
um
there are a lot of people out there who
are denied access and they actually have
to end up homeschooling or going to
other schools because they don't want
they refuse mandated vaccines
um
I can remember when my child when the
chickenpox don't think about mice is my
pediatrician actually told me not to
give my son the vaccine but to infect
him
um and now I know that's a normal
vaccine that's required to go to school
so
um you know there's different
even within the medical profession
there's different
um ideas of what should be mandated and
what shouldn't be and I I know there's
probably a set standard but if you base
it
s parents should be allowed to make they
know their children and they should know
what's best for their children
um I mean you know do we make an
exception for schools I don't know
um but I think everyone should have the
choice
let's grant that every parent has the
right to keep
the children from being vaccinated if
this bill were to pass
then
Hempstead Middle School's policy of
mandatory vaccines for a child to attend
is now gone we're not talking about the
parents rights here yeah we're talking
about the school's right to set policy
if you do not get these vaccines you may
not attend this school this bill would
um
thank you Mr chair
um honestly I didn't really think of
schools when I was talking about this
because I wasn't looking at the school
as a public
um
place because to me it's just like the
public cannot go into that school they
um it's just with children and if you
actually want to go into that school you
have to go sign in because not anyone
can walk into that school
and children can already be exempt from
vaccine vaccines based on religion
they can do religious exemptions already
yeah but is it not true then that you're
broadening the exemption to everyone and
in terms of public school being public
um I'm going to guess by its title it
probably is
okay
um
then I guess uh you would need to put an
exemption in that it doesn't apply to
that's the only answer I have
okay thank you for um answering
today's environment many
people offer to go in other words you
could order product online
um and you could actually show up and
have it delivered to your car without
having to actually go into an
establishment
um would that not
take care of a lot of the issue because
it still allows the person to order
something without having to physically
go into the store yet they can still do
their shopping they can still obtain
things that they need without violating
the the establishment's concerns about
public health would that not be a way to
allow people to still be able to shop
and do things that they want in normal
Commerce
uh thank you for the question uh
representative uh so I understand
why you would say that but they are
being denied access to food and beverage
establishments
and that is part of everyday living and
that is part of
um
you know human connection is really
important
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative control
um wouldn't you agree that this is this
practice of
um to speak to representative Merchant's
question of uh making people who have
medical conditions or psychological
conditions maybe developmental
disabilities or religious objection to
um say wearing a face mask or accepting
a vaccination this practice of of you
know having them do curbside pickup or
not allowing them into establishments is
is marginalizing a subset of society
it's a population group based on you
know their rights of conscious
conscience or or medical needs wouldn't
you say that that is
um that's what this bill is for it's to
make sure that we're not setting up
two-tiered society that
um where people who can or won't can or
will
um or do not object to certain Medical
Treatments
are allowed to participate and those who
can't who do object or can't
for medical reasons are then not allowed
uh thank you representative for the
question so yes I mean
I am seeing
even in healthy people
the that we have created
a class is already in society today I'm
looking I see the psychological damages
that's happening with children I mean
children
deal with emotion
through facial uh you can see what's
going on with the child when you can see
their facial expressions by making
everyone emotionless in this Society is
doing great harm
um but that's a separate issue so
I would say that yes we have created two
classes of citizens and not only that
because you're making people who cannot
wear one if they go into a place
the looks the stairs I mean they're made
to feel like a second rate
person and that they don't deserve to be
out in public
follow up
thank you
um to speak to the issue about schools I
think that
your bill is sort of extending the
exemptions that we provide we provide a
religious exemption and we provide
medical exemption for the requirements
for school children to be vaccinated
um so there are already unvaccinated
children in schools with vaccinated
children
and intermingling they are not required
to be you know marginalized we allow for
that so that they're not discriminated
against would you say that this bill is
just expanding on that to the public
uh thank you representative and yes it
is it's like I said nobody ever
should be discriminated against for any
reason and we have done that and I'm
seeing it I'm watching families being
torn apart over this
it is so sad what we have done to our
society
the chair recognizes representative Co
Falls
thank you
um
representative I I wanted to ask about
the the question
concerning tuberculosis or a medical
worker
um would
medical professionals potentially be
covered under
Federal Regulation 29 CFR 1630 which
does
essentially carve out a uh
a scenario in which there is a direct
threat
and can call upon the uh the the
employer to either demand treatment or
um
or or not perform their duties as normal
if there is a direct threat as opposed
as as a result of a medical condition
um do you believe that this uh this
Federal Regulation would apply under
these circumstances
thank you representative colfeld for
that and I am not familiar with that CFR
directly
um but I would assume yes because
um I deal with public policy uh over in
the environmental Agriculture and there
are certain guidelines where you know we
have to be cognizant of Public Health
um and that's very important and this is
not to take away from what's already
mandated uh in certain sections of code
this is just to say you can't
discriminate against people for not
doing something
it's not saying uh if someone has
tuberculosis or a uh you know like a
zoonotic disease or something that you
can't treat it or that you shouldn't
treat it
it's saying stop
discriminating
because people cannot where
a medical device or do not want to take
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
what you're doing what you're saying is
that people who have certain beliefs
have a right to make a choice and I
think equally everybody else has a right
to make a choice if you're a physically
vulnerable person and you wear a mask
and you choose to socially distance and
you follow all the rules
and this bill passes and I no longer
have any guarantee that the rest of the
people are not going to follow the rules
that have been generally accepted
doesn't that put me in a class that's
being discriminated against I can Nola
access a public uh
building uh
because I lack any guarantees I wouldn't
be exposed to an extreme risk to myself
so
your bill eliminates risk to one group
of party but it creates discrimination
against another whole group who you know
really believe that they cannot access
those buildings because it is no longer
safe
and I'll add two words to that uh
wouldn't you believe to make it a
question Jubilee yes all right
City representative I
uh this bill has nothing to do with
social distancing
um so social distancing can stay in
place
but it does
does have everything to do with equal
access to a public place and I'm not
saying that you cannot wear a mask I'm
not saying that someone
can't wear a medical device or take a
vaccine I'm just saying that there are
there are other people out there and
that
cannot wear a mat a medical device or do
not want to take the mandated vaccine we
should be eat we should be able to
coexist if you choose to wear a mask
you're protecting yourself and if you're
practicing social distancing because
this has nothing to do with social
distancing
follow up
yes follow up
I don't wear a mask to protect myself I
wear a mask to protect everybody else
around me
and if I can't be sure that those people
without a mask aren't ready to pass that
illness on to me even if I am wearing a
mask am I not being discriminated
against
thank you representative uh for the
question I don't believe that you're
being discriminated against because no
one's making you do one or the other or
denying you access uh because you choose
to wear a mask
however you are being discriminated
against if you choose not to
and it is about discrimination and equal
access
well I I must thank you that's that's an
answer
um representative McKay I believe you
joined the meeting would you announce
I'll get it
representative McKay if you are in the
meeting I I think you are would you
please unmute and announce yourself
oops
okay this is representative Jim McCabe
I'm present in Concord and my office and
I just finished getting my
um
inoculation
and I'm very pleased thank you very much
welcome do you have a question
no I lowered my hand Mr chairman
then let me um ask another question this
is representative Pearson and the chair
my undergraduate degree was in uh
and um so I'd like to recollect somebody
in history about a hundred years ago
named Mary Mallon
we know her better it's Typhoid Mary
and otm had three options as I see it
maybe theoretically number one was to
receive treatment until she was no
longer contagious and in the meantime be
quarantined or
if she refused treatment she had the
option to speak quarantined
or third theoretical option
she had the right to in fact we know at
least 53 people in typhoid and if this
bill were to pass Typhoid Mary could
have elected I think that third option
and so my question to representative
kantois is is this what you're intending
thank you Mr chair for the question and
no it is not what I'm intending I am not
intending to say that if
um you've been exposed to something or
have a contagious disease that you
should go out in public that is not what
I am saying
what I am saying is that a healthy human
being should not be denied access
because of their medical choice because
of their choices
now right now we have in place
that if you are near
somebody or have been in close contact
with someone who has had uh tested
positive for covid that you should
quarantine or
uh or and not go out in public until you
have had a have tested negative which I
think is fair
and no one is is denying that
should you be in denied access to a
public place a healthy human being
denied access
follow-up I do not see the word healthy
human the phrase healthy human being
here what I do see on line eight is no
individual
shall be denied a right I refuse so so
our friend here Mary Mallon could refuse
there's nothing in here that says she
has to be healthy coded to have these
rights do you agree
could you please
sorry
um
that I need to I haven't I wasn't able
she wasn't able to hear you all right
let me continue or repeat it in line
eight
says no individuals shall be denied
and I do not see the phrase no healthy
human being or no individual who is
tested negative it simply says no one
shall be denied because they've refused
treatment so Mary Mallon AKA Typhoid
Mary could be refused treatments and by
this bill she's an individual who shall
uh Mr chair
um
I I guess I I can't really honestly
answer that question because I mean
we're talking about something in history
and I don't I don't think that anybody
and and this is my personal
in good conscience would go out and
infect people on purpose
I mean
I just don't see that happening in
today's world but maybe I'm wrong
I do believe that healthy people should
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
um
you've spoken
um eloquently about the types of
psychological and material harm done to
people through
um what you describe as discrimination
um
so I am wondering
in order for us to better understand how
much of a problem this is are you aware
of any
more objective collection of data about
people who feel discriminated against
because of this any kind of surveys that
have been taken or places where
complaints are made but any kind of
information that we could have that
would tell us how big a problem this is
uh thank you for the question
representative
um I know of uh
some establishments where
go in
um with a disability and a food and
beverage establishment
um and the establishment uh called
um
the AG's office on them
um I know of an employee who had worked
within a food and beverage establishment
for over 20 years
and uh the patrons uh she couldn't wear
a cloth mask but worse shield and was
discriminated against for that
and had to cut her hours and I'm
actually not sure if she is still
employed because she was discriminated
against because of a severe medical
condition
um and this is an establishment that has
been called on
um if they saw one little infraction and
there's not many because I've uh gone in
there and almost I would say 99 of the
people are complying as well as the
workers but the Discrimination is
happening and that is just in one
establishment that I know of personally
I also know personally uh the uh folks
that were discriminated against going
into a grocery store and I know that
because of that they won't go to a food
establishment places because they have
that medical condition where they can't
go from the door to their seat
so it is happening and if I know of two
places that that's happening in My
Little Neck of the Woods
how many other places and how many other
people is this happening to would be my
question
follow up follow up that is what I'm
asking
um when you say
you know how many other places is it
happening
um
that's the question I'm asking because
we're going to be asked to vote on this
and weigh a certain kind of public good
versus
individual freedom and
um I'm trying to get a sense if we have
an understanding of how much this is
happening and how many people are
affected
um
but I guess
I would understand if there is no
objective collection of that kind of
data which it sounds like there isn't
that you know of
thank you Representative no I do not
know of any uh data at this time
the chair recognizes representative gay
thank you Mr chairman I actually have
four questions so if you'll let me just
say them all at once you can answer them
however you'd like would that be okay
yes
Okay so
if I understand right this bill is not
affecting rules on social distancing at
all that's question one number two
our employees who are sick
already not permitted to work
again I don't think uh I oh and would
you approve of um
um an amendment that just added to or
they have declined a medical treatment
adding the words for an active
communicable disease
OLS is fast so would that be okay would
that cover the concerns of allowing
someone to come in who's six
uh isn't it um non-discriminatory
to allow no masks no vaccines
because everyone else has the choice to
wear a mask or have a vaccine and we've
been told repeatedly that we should wear
masks to protect ourselves as well as
other people
so I think that covers my four my four
questions
thank you representative
um and yes I would be amenable to the uh
Amendment and it is true
um on most on all your points that you
spoke to
um you know we have to understand that
there are people with disabilities that
this mandate is doing harm to and
although people say there are exemptions
under the Ada there is not because
the federal guidelines say that it
disabilities are not uh Gone Away under
this
so people are being discriminated all
thank you Mr chair
representative
with this bill apply to elderly housing
facilities where the the occupants are
high risk
people
uh could thank you represent could you
repeat the question please
with this bill
impact elderly housing facilities where
the residents are high-risk people
to high risk to infection thank you
uh thank you for the question I don't
believe so I don't believe it would
again representative Pearson and the
chair are you aware of any federal laws
or statutes that would nullify this bill
should have passed
uh thank you uh Representative no I am
not
thank you
anyone else last call Representative
Cushman thank you Mr chairman
representative
um are you aware of the statute language
and RSA 141c that requires those who are
ill with a communicable disease to be
quarantined
uh thank you representative for the
question no I am not but that would just
be common sense
thank you follow up follow up
so with this this law then would not
override that requirement for certain
communical disease and
um the commissioner does have that
ability
um to quarantine someone who they
believe is a threat and
um on that subject
would you say that Society is kind of
tilting into
um a position where people are are
deemed sick until proven healthy
[Music]
thank you representative for the
question I wouldn't go
um
yes the commission the HHS commissioner
does have the ability to quarantine an
individual that is true I don't know if
Society has tilted that far yet
however
uh fear has been instilled into the
populace
um and I am very concerned of the
psychological effects that it is having
on our our populist
um as we speak
and I see what it is doing to uh
children we see a rise in emergency room
cases due to uh
thoughts of suicide and depression for
kids
um that is a fact that was reported in a
local newspaper
um so all of this is being that is
seeing no further hands up from the
committee the chair of things
representative come TWA for her
testimony Mr chairman it is the custom
of the committee to take representative
state representatives not in the
committee next and we have none who are
signed up Mr chairman then it is the
custom state
agencies and so the chair calls on Ani
Malachi
and he's a state agency staff member and
um Mr chair we do have one more hand up
amongst the uh the committee
I did not see it I'm sorry Ani Malachi
hey it's me I'm sorry I was testifying
Travis I I would have taken your call
good morning
thank you Annie okay yes uh good morning
Mr chair and committee members um I I do
have a point of order question do would
you like for me to continue or did you
want to recognize the representative uh
or Representatives that had additional
questions before I start I'm I'm very
okay to wait I appreciate that we have a
lot on our plate today I'd appreciate
your going ahead
okay thank you very much
um good morning uh for the record my
name is Ani Malachi I am the executive
director of The Human Rights Commission
um and I will try to without going into
too many dizzying details really try to
to sum up uh my testimony
um I do need to go backwards a little
bit to talk about the commission and
then move as briskly as possible without
moving too quickly into the topic I
would pre-appreciate gravity please
absolutely
um for those of you who may not know the
Human Rights Commission established in
1965 is the enforcement agency for New
Hampshire's laws against discrimination
we cover employment public accommodation
housing and education
K-12 was added to our Statute in 2019.
so just for the sake of the conversation
I need to read to you two definitions
for public accommodation and and then we
can move forward so in our statute which
is RSA 354-a
and the definition that I'll be reading
is in section two under definitions and
it is Roman numeral uh 14 and it says a
place of public accommodation includes
any Inn Tavern or hotel whether
conducted for entertainment the housing
or lodging of transient guests or for
the benefit use or accommodations of
those seeking Health Recreation or rest
any restaurant Eating House public
conveyance on land or water bath house
Barber Shop theater Golf Course Sports
Arena healthcare provider and music or
other public hall
store or other establishment which
caters or offers its services or
facilities or Goods to the General
Public
and then there's a carve out for private
clubs so that's fine and then the one
other thing because this if this passes
this goes into
um
354a 16.
and 16 deals with undiscriminatory
practices so there's a quite a bit there
but in a nutshell
what this tends to do and I appreciate
representative comtwa's very passionate
testimony and her patiently taking
questions and answering those and
wanting to look after the constituents
that have contacted her
um ultimately what this does is based on
the language that's there it creates
another protected class so usually a
protected class is based on immutable
characteristics and that's where we go
with age your sex your gender identity
sexual orientation those two were added
more recently race religion color
marital status physical or mental
disability national origin those things
are covered under our
laws against discrimination which are in
line with the federal laws against
discrimination the 1964 Civil Rights Act
we are a little more restrictive with
gender identity so
when you have what's written here
you are saying regardless of my physical
disability because I think that was
where the representative come to all was
trying to go this says anyone at any
point can say
I can't be discriminated quote unquote
discriminated against for not
participating in in these requirements
and we already have the Ada
which provides for that
um if it's an employment setting then
the employee has to have some level of
conversation with the employer to work
through what's called a reasonable
accommodation and there are businesses
that have created reasonable
accommodations for people who have not
been able to wear a mask or can only
wear a shield to meet them at the curb
in some places it doesn't matter what
your physical condition is they will do
curbside pickup and so what this is
doing is it won't just affect the number
of people that may have a disability
this is open to every single person who
wants to refuse a medical treatment
refuse a medical test or a vaccination
or a medical device and I'm not sure how
you would get into HIPAA to determine if
I don't want to wear a mask because I
just don't want to but someone else
can't wear a mask
because of a medical condition that's
personal information so I'm not quite
sure how we how we square that Circle
my looking at this certainly it would be
something that would have to play out in
the courts
um
and if there were someone that were
suing us because we didn't take a case
the AG's office would have to make a
determination but many businesses that
are following the guidelines that have
been presented and have the signs posted
you can't come in without a mask etc
those are things that are the law of the
land and so they are in constant
communication with the Attorney
General's office who would then make
that determination so to make this law
sort of goes around what the Attorney
General's office is doing and I don't
know
um
that would be a conversation to have
with with the AG's office I certainly
have more to say but I will pause here
and I am absolutely open to any
questions or clarifications needed I
thank you all for your time and your
patience
the chair will now entertain
questions for Ani Malachi and the
and I believe that would be
representative Woods
uh thank you Mr chair uh just as an
aside um I had my hand up for some time
uh is there another way that I should
use other than uh just raising my hand
on the side uh in the zoom uh is there a
better way for me to raise my hand I
think this was a little accident from
our normal very good procedure so I
can't think of anything okay I thought
it might be something but uh thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question and either I might be able to
answer it uh I I too had questions about
uh um uh Typhoid Mary and the healthy
individual uh the question that remains
is uh does this apply uh to the
vaccination card to get on an airplane
at Manchester Airport and the use of
masks uh in in that venue
uh thank you for your question
representative
um I would like to say yes on that
but my guess is going to be because you
are leading one States going to another
um what we dictate here would also have
to be applied in everything being flown
over so I can't honestly say that that
would apply uh
now any questions for Annie Malachi
and because of this going and
thank you Mr chairman Ms Malachi
relative to the 354a
law that you refer to
and knowing it's uh the specifics that
the bill is addressing relative to a
medical
effect on our fellow citizens does do we
have a precedent that provides
a doorway for adjustments in this bill
that is reflected in 354 810 number six
uh specifically what that refers to is
AIDS and the medical
exemption not an exemption but statement
that you couldn't discriminate if an
individual had AIDS in preventing them
from entering
a space does this not apply or would
that be similar to what is being
um representative McMahon McMahon thank
you very much for your question
um I would actually have to take that up
with the Attorney General's office to
see if there's a a similarity
um however
this is specific to people that have
one issue so that would be AIDS
um this the the bill that we're
discussing HP 506 is relative to anyone
anywhere that would refuse to wear a
mask to have a medical test to have
medical treatment
and not be able to
um quote unquote discriminate against
them so
relative to AIDS that's one segment of
the population
whereas this bill is available to the
entire population and
um and then the other piece of that
would be there could be a self uh excuse
me a health and safety issue so if I
have
um you know and we're in a pandemic so
however you feel about that if you're
looking at the um the ability of this uh
disease to be communicable and then
whatever information we know now to
attempt to slow that down or stop that
if I choose not to participate
certainly that would be my choice but
then we're removing the choice of an of
a business to keep other customers as
well as their employees safe and so a
health and safety concern would be a
plausible defense for a business if it
was an employee employer conversation
that would be something if there was a
charge of discrimination that we would
take into consideration
um so I'm not I'm hoping that I answered
any other questions from the committee
representative gay thank you Mr chairman
uh Mrs malachite how do you feel about
those of us who have hidden disabilities
uh would that mean
that in
we would have to be card carrying
disabled people
in order to be covered and protected by
bills like this
um my allergies are hidden but they put
so I mean this sounds like to be proved
to be considered protected by
anti-discriminatory bills we would have
to go get somebody to document that we
are handicapped or disabled
but if you're feeling about that
um representative thank you for the
question
um to to be very transparent I I work
really hard to leave my personal
feelings out of the conversation and
really look at the law as it stands to
understand and interpret what the
legislative body has instructed my
agency to do and in so being I have to
follow the rules that are here and we
give guidance we have businesses that
contact us we have individuals that
contact us for guidance and we
absolutely administer that guidance um
not bearing on one side more so than the
other to have to have a card of some
sort to prove a disability based on your
question that would be something that
would be above my pay grade and would
not at all be something that I would
determine what I would do is if there
was a law that stated one way or the
other then we would follow that law and
explain to individuals and businesses
what their responsibility is to follow
the law and and that is that is my that
is my job that is my due diligence to
make sure that that happens
um the Ada is available for people and I
do understand
that some people's disabilities or
illnesses are hidden but
there's nothing that I can do to force
someone to comply with the law I can
explain what the law is make sure people
understand what their rights are and for
businesses to understand what their
legal responsibilities are and then of
course the Attorney General's office for
the State of New Hampshire will
interpret those laws and further assist
businesses and individuals in
understanding what their
responsibilities are and such has
happened during this during this time as
there were fines that were levied
regarding businesses and and other
issues so
um
that would be the the most concise and
most clear answer I could give you to
that question thank you
oh well
I understand thank you for taking my
question I I
am trying to understand and accept that
you are uh
see what's the right word hindered uh
you have
strong responsibilities to follow the
law
and yet they are
putting you in a position are they not
of commenting on a proposed law
it sounds like it's kind of out of your
uh area of responsibility and
you know that I appreciate that you're
well that is that how how you feel that
you must abide by the laws
but yes this law is something different
and so it's
it's
um not in your regular responsibility
um thank you for the follow-up question
um anything relative to 354-a is my
responsibility whether it's on the books
or proposed and my duty here today is to
advise or to inform the committee should
this pass this is what we're looking at
we're looking at everyone and anyone
being able to refuse or decline medical
treatment medical tests or vaccinations
or medical devices it's not Rel it's not
specific to people with disabilities
whatever that disability is whether it's
a physical disability so autism or
someone that has a sensory issue whether
it's someone that has a medical
disability meaning allergies or
emphysema Etc the CDC has guidance on on
what businesses can do
and so maybe there's a better way to
communicate these things however there
are competing interests so I'm the
enforcer of the law well not me
personally but my agency enforces the
law as it is written
the AG's office does their level of
enforcement the CDC is providing
information we have our Public Health
officials providing information and I
mean at the end of the day hopefully
when however many people decide to
become vaccinated or enough people have
it and we have this herd immunity thing
this is a non-issue but I look at this
not relative to covid today but once the
law is on the books what does this look
like going forward
um even though we're talking about a
pandemic that is happening right now
there are other things that may move
forward and so
if I have whatever I have I am not
required to disclose that to anyone so I
could have something else that's highly
infectious and communicable and I decide
that I don't want to wear a mask or
um or or some other way to stop myself
from spreading to others I could I could
do that with the language as written the
larger concern for me is making these
individuals a protected class that adds
another protected class to the list that
we are currently responsible for where
whereas there is the Ada that deals with
people specifically with disabilities
and the hope would be that businesses
would work together with an individual
that has a disability who cannot enter
and find some common ground for that
person to be able to participate with
that restaurant or that business but you
know as we know if people are staring
and jeering or complaining about someone
this bill does not stop
the heart of someone
so what we're looking at is entering
public spaces
and being charged with discrimination
for the business potentially following
the law
so
anyone who hasn't spoken has a question
saying that I thank you for your
testimony
and we do have a hearing at 10 o'clock
and it is now 10 15. and the chair
invokes
custom where there's numerous people
willing to test or wanting to testify to
put a time limit on that
in the past when we've done this and it
has been in the committee room it's
quite easy for someone to hold up a sign
saying you have half a minute left
it's difficult to do it here and I've
been wrestling with how to do it because
the last time I did it we just simply
had people's microphones cut off that
left me unsatisfied and I'm sure left
others even more so
so I took counsel with people who've
been here a long time and this is what
they've suggested we do
when we call on
the people who have signed up indicating
they wish to speak
you will be given a certain time amounts
and you'll be given a 15-minute warning
so a 15 second warning so if you hear
something that's spoken about as loudly
as you're speaking that is your 15
second warning which means you wrap it
up and at two minutes your microphone
goes off and you go to the next person
we had a wonderful example last time of
somebody who said three very powerful
points in 38 seconds it can be done
so with that understood
um just to Christina are you uh watching
I am chairman I am also running two
meetings though I'm sorry I can't hear
you yes I am thank you so we're going to
be giving each speaker two minutes
and at a minute 45 if you could say 15
seconds to go and then at two minutes uh
we'll go on to the next person who's
called would it be possible for
representative Acton to do that only
because I have two meetings going on at
the same time and I I worry that I won't
be able to uh to keep up
my volunteer if you need a volunteer but
if representative Acton is ready to go
that's fine okay and we have you can go
back up as well thank you the chair
recognizes Mary Holland and your email
address indicates you're from the
children's
healthdefense.org so if Mary Holland
could be immunity to come into the
a quick point of order Mr chair what was
it
is that a three minute
two two minutes okay I got that and if
if you could raise her hand so I can
promote her
I'm I'm sorry if the next speaker could
raise her hand uh we have uh 98 people
in
my hand can you hear me this is Mary
okay you're good thanks great thank you
so much uh I appreciate this brief
opportunity
um I don't think there's any question
that under Public Health laws state and
federal one can isolate and one can um
quarantine people who are proven to be
infectious I think the issue really
revolves around vaccines testing and
masks all of which right now are
considered emergency use authorization
devices or products in other words none
of those things for covid-19 have yet
been proven to be effective they've been
authorized and so I think the question
to you as legislators is do you want to
participate in creating a regime around
separate but equal people who don't mask
people who don't test people who don't
vaccinate those regimes of separate but
equal all are already being put in place
around the world and even in New York
City where I exist children who don't
submit to testing which is not Urban to
be correct or accurate for infectious
status are being restricted from access
to public school they must go into
remote learning there's no question that
remote learning is not equal to
in-person learning and yet that is
what's happening so I would urge you to
consider very carefully do you want to
create that kind of society where
someone won't wear a mask or they won't
submit to testing or they won't be
vaccinated they are in effect put into
internal Exile that's the issue
thank you
thank you very much and for your your
brevity appreciate that uh the chair
and yes when you're called please put
your hand up so we can find you quickly
unmute okay all right can you hear me
Jen okay thank you so much
um I just I want to try and keep it
brief
um growing up in this great nation and
especially in New Hampshire I've always
known that America is special The Beacon
of Hope to the world I have taken for
granted my freedom and my liberties
now that I'm in my 50s time has taught
me that when we give up freedoms and
Liberties it's very hard if not
impossible to get them back I'm an avid
believer in the Constitution of the
United States and the constitution of
New Hampshire our countries are other
countries are forcing their people to
fall in line with this idea that in
order to be free you must do what we say
first that's not the way America does it
and it's definitely not the way New
Hampshire does it you can look through
the Constitution forever and you will
never find anything that would oppose
this bill it is right in line with our
great Constitution when I think
historically about the times where
having Freedom relied on doing what
you're told it was the beginning of the
end for all freedoms we all know the
countries and oppressed people I speak
of thank you so much for this bill and
this opportunity to support it Live Free
or Die I only have a follow-up thing a
couple of things for representative
Shapiro because I happen to live in the
king area
in the Keen Sentinel there was an
article about a mother who had her baby
in a pack in front of her she went into
the Monadnock food co-op and the baby
was fussing she had to take down her
mask briefly to speak to it and she took
to try and calm the baby
and she was followed harassed yelled at
humiliated in public they called the
police on her it was it was a horrific
scene according to her
um my last thing as a registered nurse
who works in Massachusetts on a coven
unit I can tell you that out in the
public we should have a greater fear of
picking up MRSA mssa C diff uh staff
those sort of things then what a mask
can protect us in the community
thank you thank you the chair recognizes
and I apologize please help me pronounce
more accurately rodaya
savalingo
surveillance
she said she's muted
thank you Mr chairman
um an honorable representatives for
offering me the opportunity to speak I'm
here to share testimony to support
non-discrimination on the basis of
medical choice
there are many reasons I am in support
of non-discrimination but for today I
would like to focus on two points first
the importance of approaching medical
Choice with cultural humility and
responsiveness
and second the need for True informed
consent
first I'd like to speak to the
importance of cultural humility and
responsiveness as it relates to
supporting individuals and making their
own medical choices I stand with my
peers who consistently advocate for the
importance of self-reflection awareness
of our own viewpoints and humble
recognition that our ways of viewing the
world are not shared by all and that is
incumbent upon us to be responsive to
those with cultural differences even
when their voices may be few and even
when we may not understand the
perspectives they represent in the past
year it has become obvious that there is
a dominant Health ideology that is
sought to eliminate all alternative ways
of thinking and seeing Life Death health
and well-being instead of responding to
a novel situation with humility and
openness to cultural religious
an indigenous approaches to health we
have instead entered a realm of
centralized authoritarian Health
dictates which seek to shame silence and
marginalize all of those who disagree
instead of responding to a novel
situation by honoring the creative
potential of our neighbors as fellow
souls to come together to express and
share their inherent Health wisdom
the public health authorities have shut
down channels of communication and
minority perspectives who have dared to
share hope optimism and encouragement
I'll close by saying it is not in our
true nature to coerce our neighbors to
ignore their inherent Health wisdom nor
should we insist they make specific
Health choices to engage in society
thank you thank you very much
the chair recognizes David Smith Esquire
good morning can you hear me yes okay
good morning thank you so much I'm
representative
and uh in support of this legislation
the genocide watch lists 10 signs of
genocide including classifying people
and limiting their rights to access to
different things based on their
classifications and the head of genocide
watch when he was confronted with the
issue of all these classifications
occurring today said
oh no this doesn't apply to our times
because everything we're doing today is
scientifically based and it's therefore
Justified to classify people and
therefore it's Justified to exclude
people
and this is the Fatal flaw of our times
that we're putting ahead that science
trumps everything trumps people's
ability to choose Trump's ability to
think for themselves and only one thread
of scientific thinking is allowed what
we have to recognize is making the
distinctions of essential non
non-essential healthy not healthy
distinctions are the distinctions that
were established in Germany as the
public health ideology took Force in
Germany in the 1920s in the Bible
Republic and then it was taken with the
most efficient execution of it through
the Holocaust where people were
identified as essential non-essential
um and was not limited to the Jews it
was limited it was attacking the people
who were not healthy attacking the
people who were considered disease
bearers of which the Jews were then
conveniently identified so death as John
Stark said General Stark said John Stark
said is not the worst of evils the fear
in hysteria today is because that has
been lost and as a result Live Free or
Die cannot be kept in effect if people
think that death is the worst of evils
our job is to make sure that cruelty
does not become the ruling Paradigm in
the name of Public Health that will
eliminate the rights of every person to
investigate inquire and make their own
decisions
the chair made a mistake earlier when I
said that um we call on people from the
state agencies earlier I uh didn't turn
the page over so the chair now calls
[Music]
if she could just raise her hand it
thank you good morning good morning
chairman and committee members thank you
for the opportunity to provide
information about the impact of HB 506
again for the record my name is Patricia
Tilley and I represent the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
Division of Public Health as Miss
Malachi and the Human Rights Commission
noted the public accommodation
definition is Broad in scope including
not only retail stores but also food
establishments and health care and as
you know there are particular
considerations that must be made when we
think about health and safety in in
these places in restaurants and
healthcare provider offices and other
areas that are included within that
definition this committee has already
thought through some of these questions
as you considered HP 220 which stated
that individuals had a right to bodily
Integrity free from threat or compulsion
and as you may recall that bill was
amended to not not limit the ability for
DHHS to order treatment or quarantine as
has been discussed in this hearing it
also was amended to not supersede the
requirement for vaccination as a
prerequisite for admission to a school
or Child Care Agency the amended HB 220
also considered that Health Care
Providers or hospitals or even other
employers were appropriate in limited
scenarios in enforcing certain
requirements for vaccine or Medical
Treatments in order to protect the
health of others and in very little
limited cases to protect the health of
the individual
you know minimizing the transmission of
infectious disease is a core function of
public health law in general public
health laws should authorize compulsory
treatment only in circumstances where
individual Behavior creates a
significant risk of transmission of a
serious disease as discussed if a
medical device includes Master face
covering HP 506 could limit Health Care
Providers from requiring individuals to
wear masks or maybe even gloves that
protect the health of others in seeking
care in the same environment
as written and discussed hb506 may
impact our ability to protect the
Public's Health from communicable
disease and the committee will have to
balance private rights with the public
health interests Public Health interest
today and public health interest in the
future thank you
thank you
the chair calls Andrew mnuse from Derry
New Hampshire
Maybe
honorable members of the committee I've
come before you in support of HB 506
this is a bill that will clarify
existing law but ensuring that bodily
autonomy is always protected as a civil
right in New Hampshire law arguably
human immunity isn't immutable uh idea
uh whereas gender identity or marital
status may not be immutable so I would
counter that argument in that way
currently the law protects equal access
to places of public accommodation for
all people regardless of age sex gender
identity race Creed color meritable
status physical or mental disability
national origin or sexual orientation
arguably whether or not I wear a facial
covering face shield take a covid-19
test or show proof of vaccination I'm
already protected under this law due to
my faith
or my physical or mental disability or
all three those can certainly account
for my protection under the law but I
believe that because of violations of
people's rights during this pandemic
that the clarification in the law is
absolutely necessary so that people like
me whether or not I have a disability is
irrelevant it this law should apply to
everybody and I I feel that uh for me I
it is a matter of faith and so I I guide
you to my written testimony Which is far
more voluminous than I can speak in two
minutes but what I want to summarize and
say is the language in this bill simply
States I have a right to buy essential
goods for my family which is a human
right to be able to feed my family
without having to be vaccinated or
tested or wear a mask wearing a mask is
ineffective masks do not work to prevent
the spread of virus there have been
multiple studies that show this I can I
can show them to you if you would like
but this bill is a clarifying act to
protect my constitutional rights the
government is instituted to protect
individual rights and I would argue that
this bill is simply uh codifying that
thank you committee members
thank you Mr
um yeah thank you sorry uh sir uh the
chair called Fred Miller from Amherst
system
Mr Miller if you wave your hand and on
no sign of Mr Miller in the uh
attendees
thank you the chair calls Randy
I'm going to pronounce it to where I was
responsible hey bear Randy a bear
if it's Hebert I apologize oh I prefer
Avera but I will take Hebert thank you
very much for the French pronunciation
yeah
um I am definitely in support of this
bill I really appreciate
um this bring being brought forward uh
yes
um with everything a follow-up and
pretty much what everyone has been
saying there really isn't any
documentation supporting masks uh
stopping the spread they had referenced
tuberculosis you can ask most doctors
masking up for tuberculosis is like
trying to swat a mosquito with a chain
link fence which is much like this virus
this bill is needed I myself am tired of
being asked
for medical conditions or exemptions or
anything to related to this in any place
I go my HIPAA rights are continuously
being violated I do not feel the need to
have to explain myself to anybody in
other states
um you know basically
um stores post the signs you read the
signs no shoes no shirt no service
that's for your safety as well but in
addition to that
if it is understood that someone is not
wearing a mask
it is their right to have their hip of
Rights protected it is understood that
if they have a mask that they are not
wearing then they should probably have a
a medical condition this is known other
states that they do not harass people
um and this is what's going on here
people being torn apart out of the Shia
fear of this the data that exists in
Health and Human Services non-existent
you haven't even isolated this virus
this virus is nowhere to be found in
this state Health and Human Services has
been requested for this information I've
had 91a requests there's nothing
supporting this
and I strongly urge that this bill be
passed for the sake of integrity and the
sake of our privacy and for the sake of
our own choice the government has the
right to protect us but the government
does not have the right to dictate
and would you raise your hand please and
um
okay yes I speak in support of house
bill 506.
the mass mandate that we are living
under currently does have exemptions for
people with health conditions that make
it unsafe for them to wear a mask and
rightfully so the problem is those
exemptions are not working
not that I do have my hip or rights but
I'll explain to you I have a disease
called multiple sclerosis or Ms it has
caused me many difficulties that I do
not want repeated or exasperated I get
an infusion that kills my B cells
lowering my immune system my doctor who
made me a lot better with this disease
advises against me wearing a mask for my
health
I trust him implicitly with my health
decisions he is a medical doctor not a
politician
he also says numerous Studies have shown
I will not harm the health of anybody
else by not wearing a mask is this virus
aerosol is small enough to get through
any mask
I have been publicly harassed by store
employees for not wearing a mask and
have been refused service I have
politely explained to them I cannot wear
a mask for medical reasons and therefore
I am exempt at two different stores
employees told me they do not honor the
governor's Health exemption I am very
courteous I always keep my distance from
fellow Shoppers and I shop at latest
possible at night I have been yelled at
across a store for not wearing a mask
and again I have a health issue that
does not allow me to wear one last do
not compare no shirts no shoes and no
service to wearing something over your
mouth and nose that impedes your ability
to breathe fresh air and oxygen they are
not the same thing and as my doctor has
told me I need oxygen to do well
I hope you vote in support of this bill
thank you Mr Tucker the chair recognizes
Kelly Potenza please put your hand up
foreign
can you hear me you can
yes I'm calling I'm calling in in to
support to strongly support this bill
and I kind of speak with everyone else
that has been saying this too and I
think it's very clear that we we have to
Define
mandates are not a law and everyone's
talking about all of these things and
and politicians are involved in this
when you have a 14 or 15 or 16 year old
person at a grocery store that is using
their dirty hand to reach into a box to
hand you a mask
um there are many people that have in
like just invisible disabilities
um A girlfriend of mine her daughter has
severe autism and can never put anything
over her face the amount of
discrimination that has been going on is
absolutely appalling I could tell you
stories and stories and stories there
was another person on here I think it
was a representative that was asking
about data you want data go on Facebook
look on health Freedom New Hampshire
look on all of these maskless support
groups that are going on there's tons of
them in the states we're talking
thousands of people that are done with
this this is protecting people's rights
this is not this virus has never been
isolated the testing is all bogus why
are we muzzling people that have
um that are that are healthy I mean you
have people walking around by themselves
outside with a mask on riding a bike it
is just crazy uh the amount of times
that I have been accosted at the grocery
store at the dump is just unbelievable
my daughter has anxiety she can't wear a
mask
my kids are home now because they can't
be in school because we're masking up
all of these kids all day long this is
just appalling we need this to pass it
is no one's looking at the medical
exemptions that the governor has in line
six that mask mandate rule just
basically gave everybody uh free will to
discriminate against everyone that you
know wants to live freely I mean I can't
I can go on and on please support this
bill
thank you Miss Potenza the chair
recognizes
and if you would put your hand up please
and
unmute
Mr chair he is in and unmuted but we
can't hear his audio
can I apologize to Mr Schmidt for that
we'll try at the end
um
the chair recognizes
William thinkston from Merrimack and
would you put your hand up please and um
news
good morning
yes good morning we can hear you thank
you thank you I would just urge your
support on this bill um as
you've heard from others I uh I support
it in September 2019 I was diagnosed
with hypothyroidism
which ultimately does affect my
respiratory system I
don't currently and will not wear a mask
and I've been subject to looks
language for both me and my family
um I just got to come down to Common
Sense ladies and gentlemen if you're
sick stay home we're all adults we know
what's best for us we know what's best
for our families
so I'd urge you to do the right thing
and let adults be adults
thank you Mr Princeton thank you the
foreign
because the address here is Pompano
he's in the room and unmuted but we
can't hear him
apologies
we'll Circle back in a few minutes see
what we can do
the chair neck recognizes Nick parent
producer will put your hand up and
unmute
uh Mr chair
um
see if you can come through here I'm I'm
here uh I would like not to make any
comments at this point I thought I was
going to be testifying on a different
bill at this point okay I've done that
now I have called on everybody who has
signed up by this morning's deadline
and I would like to Circle back just to
those that we
couldn't get so that would be Fred
so John Schmidt Steven Petty Fred Miller
we're going to try to reach you as best
surprise
representative act and I can't hear you
I don't know if you're just talking to
me uh yeah Mr Schmidt is uh we can't
hear him even though he's unmuted
okay sorry Mr Schmidt how about uh
oh
I don't see either in the list
okay so this is this is now exhausting
the list of people who signed up to
speak by the cutoff time and if there's
anybody else who either we couldn't hear
because we just had a technological
problem or you wanted to testify but you
missed the deadline just please send the
committee your written testimony and
we'll take a look at it
Mr chairman there's only three what's
that there are only three
and I've just decided what I'm going to
do
and with that we are I am now closing
the hearing on 506.
and we will take a five minute break
before we move to what is next which I
think is House Bill
602 the continuation of the recess
hearing
hello
foreign
[Music]
I have I made this archaeological dig
for each of them and I basically use
um
and then they had to dig them all out
and then tell me about the person who
so I had
like little miniature Garden things in
one and
um
so much fun and it was it was great
um well I wasn't
I I didn't really start working a lot of
hours so much I was working and I was
injured and I couldn't produce for a
long time she was having surgeries and
um
no
I was walking into the building I worked
in
um and the day after it was over we had
gotten two feet of snow
and while I was walking in and it had
metal sculptures a couple stories
no snow gems
landed right on me
yeah
so
um yeah so uh
you know when the kids were younger I
couldn't do I couldn't work at that
point
wow
yeah my kids learned how to do their
laundry when they were really yeah and
but they'd have to get their own
foreign
we'll be back and everybody here I can't
it's not muted on our end okay uh is it
muted on the other end
uh with someone on the outside line
we're here yeah okay good are we good to
go
I called to order the continuation of
the hearing on House Bill
602 FN and there's been a flurry of
activity and the fear is going to call
on uh Vice chairman Marsh to get us up
to speed on that
of the
system public hearing on reimbursements
[Music]
I personally contacted
Senator shamim's office and learned that
in 1135 waivers for the federal
[Music]
so that at least is the rest for at
least
thank you is representative Edwards to
try and sponsor of the original Bill
I do not see him in the list Mr chair
representative Weber
uh thank you Mr chair I was going to
just say that representative Marsh was a
little difficult to understand but that
time has passed so we're all set I I
would also have objected to recalling
representative Edwards who's already
testified
Courtney Tanner from the it listed as a
lobbyist from Dartmouth Hitchcock who is
opposed to
602 as originally put forward
good morning
yes great
thank you so much my name is Courtney
Tanner I'm the director of government
relations at Dartmouth Hitchcock I
appreciate that
um there's been a lot of voice about
this this bill and I'd like to add a
couple of thoughts first I want to note
that since February 2nd
um since the hearing was published we
received a lot of
inquiries from providers and concerns
about House Bill 602 both as it was
originally drafted and as amended
in that vein I just want to note for the
committee that Dartmouth Hitchcock has
supported and helped providers and
administrators submit testimony
um you will find the written testimony
in your inbox
that testimonies come from Dr will Tory
the department chair of Psychiatry at
Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical Center
Dr Kevin Curtis the medical director at
the connected Care Unit at Dartmouth
Hitchcock
Catherine wilberger the CEO of Cheshire
Medical Center
and Ben gertson who is a primary care
provider in our national Clinic
I want to back up for just a second and
remind the committee that there's been a
lot of work done on Telehealth and that
work was done last session
as you know House Bill 6
16 23 which was past last session
shifted Telehealth reimbursement and
coverage in New Hampshire
and as originally drafted House Bill
1623 was based on a premise that of
providing necessary treatment to
vulnerable populations
representative Marsha's original Bill
expanded Telehealth services for mental
for mat to special populations
however responding to a need and a
um a group of bipartisan senators and
representatives work to expand House
Bill 1623 to make it the Innovative
Telehealth bill that
um that we saw last session
thanks to representative Marsh Senator
Bradley Senator Khan and others House
Bill 1623 and shared access to for the
most vulnerable populations in New
Hampshire the elderly people living in
rural Pockets people without means just
to name a few
I was Bill 1623 also created a
commission to study Telehealth services
in New Hampshire and that commission was
charged with collecting data from
provider facilities the New Hampshire
insurance department Department of
Health and Human Services and other
sources to review that data and upon
review the commission will recommend
legislative changes if appropriate
as DJ bang report the Deputy
Commissioner of the insurance department
testified in your February 2nd hearing
there are many unknowns still it's still
too soon to make policy changes for
Telehealth in New Hampshire we must
allow the commission to study the data
that will be put forward and make policy
recommendations
House Bill 602 even as amended as a bit
premature and and I think I'm informed
at this point and so we recommend that
the um the committee vote itl for this
bill I'm happy to take any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes Kevin Curtis
from
Lebanon New Hampshire your email has
Hitchcock in it
so Mr Curtis if you would put your hand
I do not see Mr Curtis
thank you
chair recognizes you just popped in
no I'm I'm sorry this is this is Matthew
Hood uh also at Dartmouth Hitchcock
Dr Curtis
um is uh coordinated his testimony with
Courtney Taylor who you just heard from
and we had uh I think Courtney mentioned
but I would just reiterate we're happy
to have Dr Curtis available but
um we just wanted him to be a resource
for the committee so
um what what he was going to present I
think you have in writing
um and we and uh was shared with by
Courtney Tanner and we're happy to
Circle back with the committee should
you wish to hear from Dr Curtis but I
don't I don't think he's available at
the moment thank you very much
appreciate that the chair recognizes
Lindsey Staples if you would please put
good morning good morning
so hello my name is Dr Lindsay Staples
and I'm a licensed psychologist in the
state of New Hampshire I appreciate the
opportunity to share my experience and
illustrate why in mental health
Telehealth and phone services are equal
to or greater in value than in-person
services
next week will be one year since with
hesitation I transitioned all of my
patients to Telehealth due to covid I
believe that the video conference format
would adversely affect quality of care
it turns out it couldn't have been more
mistaken because these tools have
instead helped my patients get better
faster than ever
some people feel like you lose something
over Telehealth and I get it I don't
like spending time with friends over
Zoom as much as I like spending time
with them in person but therapy is not a
chat over coffee it's a medical
intervention
in the past year I've observed that
Telehealth not only preserves the
essential ingredients of effective
mental health care but also has resulted
in increased remission at the lowest
ratio of hospitalizations among my own
patients that I've ever seen
I believe there are three main reasons
for this accessibility customizability
and generalizability
first issue accessibility clinicians
agree better access to outpatient
services creates better outcomes and
reduces hospitalizations which are a
costly tool of Last Resort
second Telehealth improves my ability to
customize interventions to the needs of
the patient most gold standard therapies
involve behavioral exercises most
exercises cannot be easily simulated in
an office so clinicians end up assigning
homework crossing their fingers the
patient actually does it
over Telehealth we just do it in the
session it's not a simulation it's
reality
third generalizability there's a
principle of human learning that says
when you learn something in one
environment it's hard to carry that
learning over to another environment in
short therapy sticks when you do it at
home
I've learned firsthand why Telehealth is
the future of mental health care and not
just a substitute format during covid
and it should be reimbursed accordingly
with respect as a practicing
psychologist I would ask that the
government avoid creating interference
in my clinical decision making and avoid
restricting my ability to respond to
Trends in an evolving Market
the impact of this bill cannot possibly
match the intentions of those proposing
it it will harm patients add to cost of
care take choices away from doctors and
stifle the market if parity is not
protected thank you
say none thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes Ann Campbell
and your email says your administrator
at the Campbell houses please put your
do not see her as an attendee yet Mr
chair
you
chair recognizes
hello good morning can you hear me yes
Dr Robbins welcome thank you so much to
uh be with you all this morning um I'm
Dr Katie Robbins and I come to you as a
board member with the New Hampshire
Psychological Association and chair of
its public relations and public Ed
committee I'm also a clinical child and
family psychologist here in the Upper
Valley and travel widely to other parts
of New Hampshire
uh you know as you all know we do have
the Mental Health crisis nationally and
in New Hampshire and with that a
Workforce shortage of providers to meet
the need and these issues weren't caused
by the pandemic they're really only
worsened and we expect the issues and
the need to continue
um we would like to be on record to
oppose this bill we see it as
detrimental to these long-standing
issues
um two words I really want to highlight
access matters it should matter to all
of us and we should be doing everything
we can to promote and preserve people's
access to care in whatever form that is
and the provider's ability for that
access
um quickly two parts the audio only
Services of Telehealth in a recent
survey to providers that we did we know
that 73 percent of our providers use
Audio Only services
it's almost three out of every four
providers and why well lack of Internet
difficulties with internet visual
impairment issues sometimes just due to
privacy needs and as an example I would
have a colleague with me here this
morning Dr Atkins but he's actually
doing an evaluation of a veteran in the
Colebrook area
he expects that that evaluation will be
primarily audio only for the
difficulties I just talked about
um we want and need regulations at
clearly State Audio Only is reimbursable
and we feel the wording and this
amendment is pretty vague
lastly I just want to address the parody
of the reimbursement
really regulating parity is critical the
services we provide regular regular
regularly through in-person or
Telehealth are really the same and the
overhead cost is going to be the same if
we get reimbursed at lower rates than
in-person Services we're worried that
providers and practices might be forced
to limit the Telehealth offerings to not
lose income and that could result in
reduced access for our underserved
populations
and a negative economic impact because
there's so many small businesses of
mental health providers
um so thank you for your attention we
just really want to highlight that we
want and work hard to meet the need and
we really need to promote access and
parity so that we can do it
chair recognizes and I'm going to make a
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is John
Detroit I'm here representing the
National Association of Social Workers
the New Hampshire chapter specifically
the nesw New Hampshire is a membership
organization which represents a license
and I'm licensed social workers
throughout the state of New Hampshire I
rise on their behalf to oppose House
Bill 602 for much of what you've heard
today and I won't repeat what you've
already heard what I will say is that we
think that Telehealth has been vital
during the pandemic and we agree that it
will be vital moving forward for our
clients and other clients across the
state
but even more importantly than that we
think it's premature for this bill to
come forward uh this uh the law was
changed last year and as part of that
this committee was used to use sorry for
my puppy uh used significant foresight
in creating a commission
to review all of the questions that
you've been hearing and others that we
heard last year that commission is
active and moving forward bringing
people in to discuss these topics and is
not even required to submit an interim
report until 2022. we suggest that
changing legislation at this point is
premature until this commission is
permitted to do their work and would
respectfully ask the committee to allow
that commission to move forward with
that I will conclude my testimony thank
you very much
the chair recognizes Catherine wilbarger
from team and it looks like Cheshire
yeah
I do not see her in the list Mr chair
thank you the chair recognizes Dr
thank you very much I appreciate the
opportunity to testify before this
committee
um and it's an honor always to be able
to participate in our government process
thank you very much for this you've
received my written testimony
previously for the February 2nd hearing
and also some
Communications since then I did submit
something yesterday and
um as you know we are as psychologists
um
having a quite a time dealing with Kelly
medicine there's much to do and as Dr
Lindsay pointed out uh there's a lot of
application work that's done it's very
fast moving and uh it really gets very
very good for the patients we want to
make sure that the fees that are able to
be reimbursed by the insurance companies
remain the same as in live in in person
and in office sessions That's essential
to this when it was lower uh before the
previous bill
that I am sure the parity
um we got to a point where you could
only afford to have a very few number of
telemedicine patients and I would think
that that's uh damaging to the access to
care
we also um I've been in communication
with representative Edwards as you may
be aware as I told you in my email but
I'd like to let other people know that
he does appreciate
the negotiation problems that there are
with the individual providers not being
able to negotiate fairly in group with
the insurance companies to bargain for
these rates and reimbursements because
of federal
acts of the Sherman Act that does
prohibit that assembly
and uh
representative Edwards is interested in
finding out what can be done about that
and we do realize it's a huge issue with
the federal level and federal preemption
is involved
um but having brought that forward
um
I have contacted the chairman of the
commission Senator Khan and he is
interested in bringing that question to
his commission and I'm very very happy
about that and so I I think that we're
on the right track I hope you will itl
if this comes to a vote now or retain it
for um other purposes for the committee
thank you very much thank you Dr Warner
and with your testimony unless we have
found Catherine wilbarger
foreign
[Music]
Acton have we found her he is not in the
list thank you very much with that we
have gone through the list of those who
have signed up by the cutoff time and
with that I will bring uh the hearing on
House Bill 602 to a close and with that
I will open up the exec session on the
same while we're
depression Our Lives
we have divorced an amendment
now yes 205h uh put forward by
should anyone wish to move it
representative Marsh wishes to move it
I I think I see Dr Shapiro
on Amendment
0205h so Marsh and Shapiro
and uh representative Marsh would you
discussion because you seem to want
someone to visit well I I don't know
what to do with no he did I guess it
dies
representative Weber please
[Music]
thank you
um an amendment does not have to be
offered uh it just exists until somebody
offers it
um I am a little at Sea because I heard
I did not hear the amendment number I'm
sorry
H okay goes back to February 2nd okay
um there is no need to offer it if
anybody if people don't want to offer it
I I my understanding from the chairman
is it has been offered and seconded and
I didn't see or hear representative
Shapiro seconding it so if he wants to
Second it that's fine I don't want to
stand in his way but I also don't want
him co-opted if he wasn't doing that I I
did not second it thank you okay and
representative Marsh which is no longer
to move it
so it will seem yes representative Marsh
thanks Mr chairman I what I wanted to do
was to move to retain House Bill 602 I
would be happy to speak to that okay I
had to give I believe I had to give the
theoretical possibility that somebody
would want zero two zero five H but I uh
I don't see that anybody does so your
motion to move 602 is in order
and Mr chairman may I second
representative Marsha's motion
and representative Marsh please speak to
your motion uh thank you Mr chairs uh
first of all we've had considered an
amendment an amendment is in existence
to do so
um
to make this bill to the study committee
but we already have a study committee to
study Telehealth reimbursement and I in
fact am the vice chairman of the
Telehealth talk study exhibition so I
know that this in fact happened
um I we also heard an awful lot of
testimony uh about assuming
reimbursement for auditing only
currently Audio Only is allowed on a
temporary basis by a federal 1135 wait
I contacted uh Chuck Henderson and
Senator Shaheen's office and he has told
me that the the president is committed
to maintaining Audio Only reimbursement
on a temporary basis at least to the end
of the year and hopefully to the end of
the program
so there's no action needs about that
immediately however we're that waiver to
go away at the end of the year you may
need to do something and this bill would
provide a vehicle to the Telehealth
commission that the vehicle is needed at
the end of the year and therefore I
think that retaining this bill at this
yes
yes representative snow
yes I had a question my understanding is
that
representative Edwards had added 180 day
transition after the state of emergency
ends which extends it a little bit uh
but if that state of emergency ends say
in September of this year that six
months would run to February and it's my
understanding that the final reporting
on the bill is required until June of 22
so there could be a gap where all of
those Provisions would go away for a
period of time am I correct about that
or am I not correct about that
okay
representative Marsh yes I'll be glad to
answer the question right now House Bill
623 is signed into the law so nothing
goes away until it unless we change it
in the statutory lock with the exception
of the federal uh uh waiver which is
temporary and is really entirely out of
our control so if the federal waiver
does go away then that would create a
problem you're permanently correct about
that however I have received assurance
that it will remain in place at least
through the end of the year I understand
that there are efforts undergoing on a
federal level to continue it on a longer
basis and perhaps permanently but at
this point in time we have statutory law
resting on a temporary Federal waiver
and I'll follow up
and all of those include all of those
include telephone only is that not
correct
the the federal 1135 waiver is spent
allows reimbursement particularly from
Medicare and Medicaid for audio only if
that were to go away it would not matter
what the state of New Hampshire does
representative gay
thank you for taking my question
does this mean that we
we are safe in return retaining it or
should we do a very simple
um amendment that wipes out the wording
of the wording that's currently in there
and just say that it extends uh
Telehealth
it is my opinion that you do not need to
extend Telehealth because it's our Audio
Only television because it's already
it's Statewide at this point however the
Telehealth commission might need a
vehicle to address the change in the
federal law if this waiver is not made
permanent and if it were to go away
follow up
so so if I understand properly does this
mean that you're recommending
retention and as the time progresses by
the end of the year we'll be in much
better shape to figure out what to do
to extend tell about someone my
intention as the vice chair of the
Telehealth commission would be to bring
back to this committee any
recommendations from the Telehealth
commission including any recommendations
for legislation which might include ICL
in this bill come full once we have more
information it depends upon what we
learned over the course of the coming
months however if we it out this bill
right now we have no vehicle and if the
attempt an amendment it must go through
all the hopes it must be done brilliant
and it's got to be out the door by
Thursday afternoon I don't think there's
the food is going to build this
complicated so I would suggest also that
we retain it to have it as a vehicle
anyone else from the committee
remember it doesn't have to be a
question because this is an exact
session I'm thinking I'm seeing
I think I am seeing yes representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um
I have a question and then I have a
comment my question really is
um to representative Marsh
and my assumption and I could be wrong
was that the federal waiver applied to
Medicare only and that's so our state
law really can't mandate what Medicare
pays for
um but are you saying that also
um affects
how we can reimburse for Medicaid
uh it is my understanding that CMS is
the center for Medicare and Medicaid
services and therefore yes it would
affect Medicaid I'm not sure that's
accurate I don't know if we could get a
you know if there's someone like from
the insurance department or somebody who
knows
um
my second
um points which is not a question is
it's my feeling that the initial
um
hb602 was so skewed in terms of
doing away with some of the parity and
some of the um access to care that comes
with Telehealth
um that I would prefer to see at itl
and um and to really
um give respect and time and
consideration
um to the commission which is I think
um not skewed and would come at this
with a more kind of independent
objective look at what needs to change
if something does need to change and
that we start all over
um you know I'd be okay with it being
retained but I would prefer it being itl
I don't know if at some point in this
discussion if we could take a straw vote
um to see how other people feel we could
do that after a little bit the
difficulty is if we start over from
scratch it probably will not be signed
into law until a year from this June
whereas if we retain it and make an
I'm sorry
would be fine with me if it took longer
okay
uh representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman
um a series of comments
first of all there is nothing in the
bill as it stands that I like I am
firmly opposed to uh dropping the audio
only option and I am firmly opposed to
dropping parity so that's item number
one
um item number two is there's nothing in
any of the Amendments that we have seen
to date that I like
so that's just my position my own
personal feeling that I want on the
record
uh the third thing is that we have in
front of us now a motion to retain and
so having people testify about what the
federal
mandate may or may not be is
at least tangential
and possibly interesting but we have a
lot of work in front of us that I would
like to get to so
um my position is that I would be
willing to retain with the thought that
if we decide to amend this bill the only
thing I would be voting for would be an
amendment in its entirety that that
addressed completely different aspects
of Telehealth which will require new
notice and new hearings but we can do
that it will allow us to do some kind of
necessary tweak on an expedited basis
and my opinion is that
it's okay to have the bill out there in
case we need to do that and we can fight
whether it's necessary to do it or not
then rather than now but I will not be
supporting either of the two major
premises of this bill I will support
retention because I think it gets us
farther forward at least and might get
us on to the next Bill thank you
the only time
representative Edwards
180 day extension
or transition period comes into being is
if the original bill passes it has
absolutely no bearing if the bill is
being retained or anything else I am
assuming I correct about that is that
right
representative Marsh yes
what how much time do we save by
retaining the bill and working on it as
opposed to starting fresh you said
otherwise we would be a year and a
couple months before it could be signed
does it really save us any time if we're
retain it that doesn't happen the same
representative whoever you've been here
a few times
what would you say to that question the
time frame for retention is that we will
have to as long as the deadlines aren't
shifted again and let us all hope that
we don't need to do that uh that the
committee will have to report the bill
out sometime around the end of uh
October and the house will vote on it
sometime uh at the very beginning of
January and then it will go straight
over to the Senate what the Senate does
with it is the Senate's business so the
Senate might decide it was a really
important bill and they could pass it
the third week in January and send it
winging on to the governor's desk or the
Senate could hold it and deal with it
under their regular uh calendar which
means that it wouldn't have saved any
time at all but what we are doing is
preserving the possibility that it would
get acted on in an expedited fashion if
that were necessary and agreed to buy
pretty much everybody so we're just
holding on to a possibility here there's
no guarantees one way or the other if we
started a new bill obviously it's not
going to get to the governor before May
or so unless somebody acts on it in a
very expedited basis which we have done
but
unlikely in this case
representative Shapiro has suggested
a straw poll
why
my question was why would we do a straw
poll why don't we just vote on retention
representative Shapiro had thought with
Mike I don't want to retain and would
prefer another motion such as itl they
are certainly free to vote no on
retention
uh well I wanted to give representative
Shapiro the courtesy of what he had
asked for and representative Shapiro do
you still wish to ask for straw poll are
you ready to vote
well I guess I I wanted to find out if
there was any sentiment for itl in it I
would certainly go along with retaining
it
um
it seems to me that it seems to me that
a whole new bill could be brought if it
addressed different issues about
Telehealth for the next year and I think
that this bill is
um skewed and
um
you know is not the bill to be passed
and that we should give the time for the
commission to do its work
um I will certainly I would certainly
if there's not a sentiment of wanting to
itl it I would certainly go along with
retention
I didn't hear a sentiment to itl and is
there one
I would if I may Mr chairman hey
I have expressed my sentiment that the
bill as it stands ought to be itl'd but
given the time frames and other
considerations I am willing to vote to
retain so having given my word on that I
will vote to retain
it's not a question of my sentiment it's
a question of of tactics and uh having a
vehicle available in case we need one uh
we've all seen bills that have been
taken and changed to something very very
different from what they were when they
were filed and we've also seen bills
that have been captive uh and changed
into something diametrically opposed to
what their original intent was that
happens in the legislature and if that
happens with this bill fine
um
I I I'm not in I just want to make it
clear I'm not in favor of the bill as it
is but I'm perfectly happy to go ahead
with retention representative Weber I'm
of the exact same sentiment uh what you
just articulated
representative gay I agree with y'all
and so I was wondering would it make
would it be more palatable if we first
amended it to wipe out everything that's
in it and just say something to the
positive effect of Telehealth so that
when we retain it it doesn't retain all
this negative stuff
well first of all I don't think that's
necessary and secondly I don't want to
do this on Thursday so probably no
well I did not hear a great sentiment to
itl as except as
um a couple of us have said about at
least it's a vehicle it might work and
if it doesn't work we can ideal it later
so without objection I would like to ask
a question Mr chair you may ask a
question
thank you representative Marsh just to
restore my confidence in the Commission
in addition to you who I do have
confidence in can you tell me who serves
in that commission from this committee
and if there are other representatives
from mental health uh Behavioral Health
in general that sit in that Commission
uh I could pull that up for you it's on
the general court website Senator Khan
is the chairman oh yeah okay the agenda
of what we are going to be discussing on
a monthly basis over the next year has
already been put out
um and that's available on the website
it's hard for me to pull the website up
while I'm also I know I know it is do
you know if there's anybody else from
this Committee in addition to you that
serves on it
so I don't recall how I can pull up the
minutes that would be the way in front
the house committee Services people have
just said they can forward the link to
everybody on the committee about this
myself representative Woods who as you
know is also in our committee year Dr
Jonathan Ballard Tyler Brennan Sabrina
Dunlap Mary Lowry from the hospital
association bill writer from Community
Behavioral Health Association Patrick
Poe from the medical society Joe from by
State Department here and Norton from
Nami uh Tim Mohan uh Rachel and Scott
you have restored my confidence thank
I see a few yellow hands but I can't
quite recognize who they belong to
representative Shapiro
yes having not heard any outpouring of
support for itl I would withdraw a
request for a straw vote and
um suggest that we
um go ahead with our vote on retaining
the bill which I hear As you move the
question
so the question and yeah the question
before us is House Bill 602 FN
and it was moved by representative Marsh
and a second echoed seconded by
representative Solway and the motion is
to retain the clerk may call a question
okay
I thought it was
here in this room has been on you it's
best okay
representative Marsh votes yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes
representative Acton yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Alexander yes
representative King yes representative
copault yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay
yeah
representative knurk yes
representative Solway yes representative
Cannon yes representative yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant yes
representative Pearson yes 21 years zero
nurse and the bill is retained
consent
this ends the exact session on House
Bill 602 the chair recognizes
representative Solway uh for consent Mr
chairman
okay oh it's retained sorry
my apologies that's uh all right uh
several Lewis we're about to say it
opens the hearing on the exact excuse me
the executive session on House Bill 506
which we occurred earlier
this morning
relative to equal access to places of
public accommodation the chair
recognizes representative Woods for
emotion
uh thank you Mr chair I move that uh
House Bill 506 said the itl'd
thank you and the second second I'll
second that I heard a soprano voice
verse
the soprano was probably Weber
oh I'm second so we'll second if you
want
no go ahead Weber you're fine hey to
settle this uh representative Woods
moved and representative snow gets to
second on itl and representative Woods
would you speak to this motion please
uh well since we just heard this there's
probably not much I can add
my basic feeling is that uh there is a
attempt to make a balance uh between the
uh rights of the individual versus the
rights of of the uh people of
accommodating uh entities uh
nevertheless I think this this bill uh
clearly would allow someone like as you
said Typhoid Mary uh would be go would
go unchecked uh and there's a variety of
other things which are imminently uh
fresh on our minds so I won't go over
them again uh but I'll leave it at that
German uh okay representative Solway
then representative Cushman
uh uh thank you Mr chairman
um I I I'd like to borrow a custom from
representative Woods who has on occasion
said I will speak from 30 feet and I
will speak from 30 000 feet uh an image
which I rather like
um
I have worked in uh government within
this body and I have worked in public
health and I will con confer I I excuse
me I will agree with some in support of
this bill in that public health is
occasionally a science
and occasionally it is a religion
propounded by people who tell us we know
uh what's good for you and if you only
do what we tell you to do your life will
be better uh the difficulty is that we
really can't discriminate between the
science of Public Health which has saved
countless countless lives over the
generations and those aspects of Public
Health which are more realistic and
religion and prescriptive but not
necessarily terribly well founded in
such circumstances
what we do in response is to practice
what we call the precautionary principle
and it's vitally important if we do not
know for certain
however we suspect that there is a
possibility
we behave as though we were certain
knowing that we may be proven wrong but
at least we will have avoided
unnecessary disease and potentially
death
I understand and appreciate the concerns
for individual freedom I appreciate
uh the concerns about whether masks are
effective or not however
I have read the literature going back to
Julius Roberts
uh seminal article called Magic and
ritual in control of contagion in which
he talks about the use of masks do we
know absolutely for certain no we don't
however it is imperative that we
practice a precautionary principle and
therefore I would support a motion to
itl this bill uh with confidence thank
you for your attention
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman
um I would rather see this bill retain
so it can be worked on
um I I hear that we have some agreement
that individual rights need to be
um protected
and perhaps there's some language here
that could be worked out and we could
come to an agreeable form of this bill
that we could pass so that we are
protecting the religious Medical
rights of individuals
so I would just like everyone to vote
down this motion of itl and so that I
anyone else yes Mr chairman yes
representative snow
the reason why I vote for itl really is
born out of what we call the Declaration
of Independence from 1776 which Begins
by saying that we hold these troops to
be self-evident that all men are created
equal and if they were endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
that among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness if we assume
their intent was to prioritize those
three rights I think we'd have to agree
that the right to life and to protect
life is the first priority and that
Liberty would include the the kind of
freedoms that they're talking about not
that they aren't important but our first
obligation is to protect people's lives
and I think that's what the intent of
these bills are for and thank you for
your thank you for listening
thank you representative snow is there
anyone else in the committee that wishes
to speak
representative gay I submitted thank you
thank you Mr chairman I submitted a
an amendment that would have brought
corrective wording to that that
concerned people about sick people
uh just
pretending that it didn't matter that
they would go anywhere they wanted to
and uh so OLS is pretty fast so I just
wanted to say that I did submit that
a couple hours ago
anyone else
yes representative King thank you Mr
Speaker yeah Mr chairman didn't want to
elevate you no
[Music]
um so thank you Mr chair
I guess I'm a little confused because
the way I was reading where I was
reading this bill
is that it was about the Discrimination
discrimination and yet I hear a lot of
the discussion is about
whether it's the right thing to wear a
mask or not and
um
I I'm with uh representative Cushman
that we should take another look at the
language because it's apparently
confusing
representative canark
thank you Mr chair
um basically my feeling is that this uh
by accepting this we uh take away the
right of the business
um or the organ well the business I'll
leave it that way to be able to set
rules that they wish to enforce in terms
of people in their establishment and
we're not again we do as as the we spoke
about with the person who testified
earlier there are protected groups and
they would be still protected so you
can't discriminate because of
um issues of of race or gender and so on
but the issue is in public health we
sometimes have to uh lessen some of our
individual rights
for the safety of the population as a
whole and I think that if a business
wishes to set up a rule that says that
they want to protect their customers
and their employees
that the person who wishes to patronize
without wearing a mask still has the
perfect right to not wear a mask they
just go somewhere else where they don't
really care
and so that freedom is still balanced
they still have a freedom to go
elsewhere if they choose to do so but we
preserve the freedom of that business to
protect their other customers and to
protect their workers so I definitely
vote itl
is there anyone else in the committee
who wishes to speak there's two
hands-ups yeah but I can't identify them
so uh hand number one can speak
I thank you Mr chair and Don thank you
everybody for your time
obviously this is a a tough one we've
been through the ringer on mask issues
um it's hit really close to home with
this body
um it's important to remember that the
the issue with mass has been highly
politicized one year ago today is when
Dr fauci made the statement that we
didn't really have to wear masks then
several months later he admitted he did
that because he didn't want to create a
run-on masks that would take them away
from first responses responders and it
wasn't until April of 2020 that the CDC
finally came out and said yes we need to
wear masks so this whole situation got
off on a on a bad foot now
having said that my wife leaves the
house every single day
and goes out into homes with people that
are effective with covid and never got
it because she wears her mask every day
so there's a lot to this
um ultimately I I'm I'm going to vote um
to retain so that this this discussion
can continue rather than just to itl
But ultimately as it stands right now I
I wouldn't um
I wouldn't support putting this into law
like if
thank you and hand number two
other hand thank you thank you Mr
chairman
um I too would prefer strongly prefer to
see this bill retained
there are very valid differences of
opinion in the medical community
um there are uh there are valid
differences opinion as to the wisdom of
uh taking the the covid vaccine
currently there are valid differences of
opinion regarding masks
um and certain medications that can help
to treat people with covid
um
you know I I hear the the concerns about
the rights of businesses the problem is
that when every business out there is is
is Towing the party line
there may very well not be another place
to go
um if uh if you want to uh I mean even
before the mass mandate if you wanted to
go somewhere and Shop without a mask you
were suddenly starting to be very
limited because the the all of the the
bigger stores were uh were issuing their
own kinds of mandates and that was
quickly followed
um you know there are a lot of people
who for whatever reason cannot wear a
mask I don't think that it is
moral for us to force those people to
constantly explain themselves I have an
issue with that I know people who are
very upset by this I have spoken to
people in our state who have said they
are thinking about moving out of New
Hampshire because they are so upset by
this they're also not sure
what their other options are in terms of
where they can go
but this is a deeply held belief there
are very valid differences of opinion in
uh in in medicine
um and you know I I think that
representative Acton put it well which
is that this is an important discussion
and I think it is it is uh our our duty
It's Our obligation to continue the
conversation around this issue with
whichever side of this issue you are on
I think that we ought to be continuing
this discussion
um I I also will say that I think some
of the concerns about
um you know
tuberculosis you know medical workers
with tuberculosis or or typhoid are are
overstated
um partially because I think most people
are responsible and I just don't think
that that is a is a likely scenario and
partially because I think that there are
other laws already in place that cover
that we we amended HB I think it was 220
or 221
um to to call out some of those
exemptions specifically so this bill can
be made to work
um it it does need some clarifying
language and I think that it is an
important issue that we as a committee
ought to continue to stay engaged on and
that's why I would prefer to see this
retained
representative Marsh uh thank you Mr
Turner as many of you know I spent some
time over the last year on the
governor's economic for the opening task
force
and one of the principles that we
maintain throughout the year was that
businesses had the right to put
restrictions in place in their own
business as they saw a fit to protect
themselves and their employees
to me it's fairly clear that the intent
of this bill is to override that such
that people who
maintain a business that caters to the
public would not be able to put such
restrictions in place
uh to me that's a step too far on the
other hand I agree with several
Representatives who said the
conversation needs to continue I agree
totally the conversation needs to
continue
I believe that we did take a step in
this Direction with Hospital 220 which
we amended and passed
um but I think that we were very careful
and wanted to do that not to remove from
businesses the right to put whatever
rules in place they thought they needed
to in their business to protect their
employees which is the line that I am
not willing to cross and therefore I
and we'll do a quick run to
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman yet oh Lucy
representative Cushman okay
um thank you Mr chairman I I just want
to speak to representative Marsh's Point
um about businesses I think that many
many businesses are requiring masks for
entry because they are facing pressure
from local Health officers from the
Attorney General's office and they do
not understand or feel that they cannot
accommodate people who are exempt under
emergency order 74. so I would I would
suggest that this bill be retained and
maybe we can put in a clause
or you know no one shall be forced you
unless
um
unless the owner of the business doesn't
you know unless the business owner makes
the policy for their business because
then that would allow
other businesses who don't want to force
customers to wear masks to feel like
they have the freedom to make that
choice because right now with all the
pressure coming from the AG and the
health officers and the threats of fines
that businesses are getting
even though peop the public is exempt
under certain conditions from wearing
masks
they still feel that they have to force
customers to wear masks and I've I've
talked to many businesses about this so
I I would really press that
um that my fellow committee members
would um vote no on the itl so that we
can retain and work on this Bill thank
you representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman I have only two
points that haven't been made to date uh
the one is
I very much understand the concern for
the rights of the individuals that are
trying to be addressed here uh but the
other thing that I see is the equally
important rights of individuals most of
whom are either elderly or are medically
fragile
and those are people who the coveted
pandemic has particularly circumscribed
their lives and
both in this time of
um you know right now we're operating
under an emergency order which will go
away when uh circumstances change
um and my hope is that that will be
sooner rather than later but we don't
know so I'm comfortable with the way
things are under the emergency order
being aware that when the emergency
order goes the mass mandate goes too and
there will be no reason for anybody who
owns a business to do anything other
than State their own position and then
people can vote either with their their
feeder with their dollars
but I do want to just remind people that
um cloth masks don't protect
the person who's wearing them
particularly well they they do certainly
protect them somewhat but
um I I do want to remind people that
we're balancing the rights of two
different groups of individuals it's not
just individuals versus the government
and and that's a really tough balance
and I I get it that it's a difficult
question but I'll be voting for The itl
thank you
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman
um this is a I don't believe this issue
has been raised but my concern is going
to be the elderly particularly in the
nursing homes the way this bill is
written uh there's nothing to prevent a
person from going into a nursing home if
the nursing home is trying to
protect their elderly we know of that
Cove has been rampant in some of the
nursing homes and so forth and the
ability for them to shut down
um the entrance into their establishment
to protect the album they think it's
important and the way this bill's
written today that would not pertain
they would actually have the right to go
into the building whether a nursing home
believed that was right Public Health
policy so because of those reasons I
would vote
the motion by the way
um I'm getting some what used to be
called blue sheets
uh people riding in with a physician
supporting the bill 500
opposing the bill 84.
neutral two
and for the record on the previous well
I'll do that afterwards the motion
before us made by representative woods
and seconded by Representatives snow on
House Bill 506 relative to equal access
to places of public accommodation the
motion was it out did the clerk please
call the roll
thank you Mr chairman representative
Marsh yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Acton no
representative gay no
representative Cushman now
representative Folsom yes
representative Alexander
representative King no
representative co-fault no
yes
representative McKay yes
representative snow yes representative
yes representative Solway yes
representative Cannon yes representative
Nutter Upham yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes
thanks
15 years six names and representative
Woods if you would be psychiatrist to
write the committee before
I will do so sir and I will have it on
the proper form this time
laughs
yes representative Chrisman I
volunteered to write the minority
reports and representative story writes
The Minority Report I just assumed it
okay
thank you and for the record for the
last bill that we retained 602
six people signed in and support one
person was neutral and 226 people
opposed
is the sex session
much
I opened the
requiring Health Care Providers to
furnish upon requests
a list of ingredients contained in an
injectable medication that is
recommended or administered and we first
which is an amendment brought to us on
February 25th by representative Marsh
and representative Merchants would one
of you like to speak to the amendment
please yes Mr chairman I'll be left
but the amendment does it clarifies what
a list of experience is by federal law
for injectable medications and active
ingredients are required to be listed on
this label
for injectable medications and so
therefore this allows the iconic label
or a copy of the label which is on file
on the
archive of the medicine federal
government to be printed out and given
to someone who requests it as a list of
the ingredients and the facility is a
privilege it's actually important
because we're moving the label from an
it also pays attention to what the FDA
guidelines are what
connect with ingredients must be listed
uh
thank you did we move and second this
I don't believe something I don't think
we did I will move uh Amendment zero
five zero seven representative Merchant
would you like to second I will second
it seems to me that the amendment keeps
the hearts of what the original bill was
about but makes it more practical or
anyone else
Mr chairman yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman I totally agree it
retains the intent of the original bill
um to provide the information to a
patient or their caregiver
that also does exclude
situations in which we talk about with
clinical trials and having to break the
trial which would not be beneficial to
the patient because they're the ones
opting into a trial and number two it
does exempt in emergency situation where
the provider believes at that point in
time the need to care for the patient
trumps if you will the right to get the
information
foreign
representative Weber thank you very much
and thank you for taking my question I
seem to be on I I seem to have once
again lost track of my Amendment so I
can't find it and put it right in front
of me but what I my question is is
does the amendment address the problem
that we were spoken to about the bill
um it sounds to me like what you've done
is just say the list of ingredients that
would be on a label if if there were a
label as opposed to somebody approaching
your car with a with a shot
um or sitting in your whatever
um
that the list of ingredients is going to
be made available to them
um but we're not going to require
more than what is required currently
federally in terms of labeling uh
because my my concern here is making
sure that we don't run a foul of uh
Federal preemption or the Commerce
Clause or all of those things that made
my eyes glaze over in law school and
that I haven't thought about as much as
I ought to have since uh or maybe I'm
very glad I haven't thought about them
since uh so that that's the concern that
I hope has been addressed and I'm
willing to take your Assurance for it if
but if you look at the amendment and if
you look online so 15 to 17 what it says
is a list of the medications ingredients
it's a copy of the label on the
injectable medication that's regulated
by 21 CFR section
201.100 B5 whereas listed in the
dailyvee database maintained by the
United States National Library of
Medicine uh to um 100 V5 it's exactly
the exactly that you're referring to and
so therefore it does not take any uh
requirements
thank you very much I appreciate it
what else
yes uh Mr Mr chair representative yes I
just wanted to ask a question regarding
the mechanics then of how this would
work
so the prescription drug manufacturer
provides this information
uh you have a patient in the office they
request this information
as a provider
um where are you going to as a provider
be able to find this information quickly
print it and give it to the patient just
how does that work from a practical
point of view either office or hospital
representative Martian
another question uh you would be able to
copy the information off the label which
could be done simply by taking the label
putting it in your copy machine or you
can access the dailyved database which
is a public database and turn out a copy
of labels remove the label from the
bottom
thank you
any other questions about the amendments
representative I'm going to guess Woods
I'm sorry just a comment uh also uh what
we did in the office uh was if someone
had a question uh oftentimes for uh side
effects we just gave him the answer the
package
and that's very simple uh and if uh you
run you can photocopy that uh as well
because
here representative Shapiro I I wish
first I I wish to apologize to the
committee on fighting an optic migraine
which is making the AC the screen less
wouldn't be getting more confused than
normal but representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um
I admit to also losing track of the
Amendments and the original bill
um so but my memory is that in the
original bill this applied only to
people who requested the information
um spontaneously that it was not
something that had to be offered to
every patient yes that is that still in
effect in the amendment
foreign
[Music]
seeing no further
hands up to ask a question or make a
statement
we are voting on the amendment may I
just say one thing we're still trying to
find to find it
um obviously if you have a search
function you just search under Marsha's
name because he sent it out but likewise
um it came out on February
25. it's an email from Bill Marsh
February 25 at uh trying to find out
what time eight o'clock in the morning
so if you look back in your mailbox at
that point you'll be able to see the
amendment
would people like me to sort of what
level of the amendment please I'm
sending it out again so you all have
I have just sent it out
um for the members it's in your
committee email so we'll wait to see the
amendment and not just pass the bill to
just to kill time I'd like to ask a
question Mr chairman yes we do
representative how does that affect uh
medications that are uh shots injections
that are made out of the country they do
this in uh China and they ship it over
here because I have to provide the same
yes
simple answer is yes representative
Nelson
um the manufacturing of the product is
not what's driving what has to be
provided it's what country is being
shipped into so if it goes into the US
has to comply with U.S laws if it goes
into Canada complies with Canada law so
in this case because the product came
from India or China when it comes to the
let's vote
give folks a few minutes more to read
it's a short Amendment I'm good
I'm trying to get caught up with
paperwork so oh okay
okay
Amendment
zero five zero seven H to house bill
146.
moved by representative Marsh and
seconded by representative Merchant with
the clerk please call the rule thank you
chairman Pearson
representative Marsh yes representative
McMahon yes representative Nelson yes
representative Acton yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Alexander yes
representative King yes representative
yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative snow
[Music]
representative snow yes thank you
representative knurk yes
representative followway yes
representative Cannon yes
representative yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes
representative merchants
yes
yes and representative Pearson yes 21
years zero News 21 to zip uh
representative Merchant I call on you
for a motion you sure can Mr chairman
I'll make a motion to ought to pass with
Amendment
amendment number
um zero five zero seven
and representative Cushman
now we just discussed it pretty much but
we'll give a few seconds in case anybody
would like some more
clarification I realized that the
Amendments that I have been reading are
not Amendment zero five zero seven
um if I look at the amendment sent by
representative Marsh
zero six seven eight and it's to 503.
um
okay I've got another one from
representative Marsh and I've I've got
it now I I had clicked on the wrong
thing so uh thank you very much I will
be quiet now appreciate it it's a tricky
business of doing things the way we're
doing it and you know what we're gaming
on it every week
we'll have it all Mastered by the time
so any further discussion on
House Bill 146 is amended as moved by
representative Nelson to speak or
leftover
shooting nothing more forthcoming when
the clerk is ready please call the roll
for House Bill 146 as amended by zero
five zero seven H moved by Merchant
seconded by Cushman the motion is ought
to pass as amended
thank you chairman Pearson
representative Marsh yes representative
McMahon yes representative Nelson yes
representative Acton yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Alexander yes
representative King yes representative
yes
representative leper yes
representative McKay yes good
representative snow yes
representative nurse yes
representative Solway yes representative
Cannon
yes
representative Netter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes
21-0 representative Merchant please
write the committee report the chair
regret site did not have the information
as to who signed in for what
um and I've put in a request when they
have the time because it's right it's
very busy right now for the record if uh
the fourth floor would send us out all
of us copies on that chair Mr chairman
could I ask for consent
um without objection consent
include 146.
and I want to squeeze one more in before
lunch
and the representative Marsh would you
tell us what the amendment is that you
just wrote me a note about so we'll
watch for it uh yes I tested out to the
committee a new Amendment on House Bill
503 uh this is the amendment that
representative Shapiro and I worked on
last week to
find the duties of the proposed homeless
uh mentioned into the existing
commission that was discussed with us
and established by the governor's
executive order the new Amendment
correct one word in the prior Amendment
uh because we've learned that the
community's Behavioral Health
Organization was that and not the
community mental muscle Association so
and what is its number
[Music]
except we're not on that bill
Bill
no I just did that no we're on 381 I was
just asking you to let us know what we
it's your turn
uh all right with that the we opened the
executive session on House Bill 381 FN
and uh representative Marsh you are
recognized for a motion
[Music]
and do we have a second
second
second from Merchants thank you and
representative Marsh please speak to 381
FM yes this is a bill to allow
people to access Laboratories in the
state of New Hampshire for testing for
those positions
this is similar to a bill we've had
prior year one of the interesting things
that has happened since last year is at
least to my knowledge since last year
everybody
is there are numerous sites across the
state of New Hampshire right now where
people can go and get tested done
without studying positions order but
then those lab tests are then sent out
of state because our labs are not able
to perform this testing at this point
this bill would allow our New Hampshire
Laboratories to complete on a equal
basis for the out-of-state labs and
perform testing if they so desire
and I believe that that is helpful I
think it's very helpful if patients have
a concern they want their lab tests done
and the doctor doesn't particularly
enthusiastic about the idea it's much
better for them to be able to still get
their lab test done and turn on expense
and get them to a fight for their doctor
the major argument against this bill was
a argument that the public would be put
at risk uh due to the fact that people
might not be able to serve regular
laboratory tests correct I would contend
that this has been going on for some
time that these sites are currently
available and that has not happened and
that is why I support this legislative
any questions or yeah I have a problem I
I cannot find that amendment I thought I
had it now it's my turn not to have it
uh
is the one we're discussing right now no
we're discussing Hospital 381.
I thought he had an amendment on it no
no Amendment amendment was on something
else my apologies hey
okay
um
I just understand that we do have Labs
that will send it out of state and you
can do that
the problem I have I still have great
reservations about allowing this
and I view this as a little bit like
your kid coming in and saying but all
the other kids are doing it just because
all the other kids are doing it doesn't
mean you're going to condone them
starting to smoke
it's and I think the fact that other
states may be doing this
and we might lose business to those
other states does not make it a good
idea to condone that behavior because by
so doing
we will probably increase the amount of
these tests that would be done
um and I do not think that that's really
necessary and I think not necessary
because
it there are very clear issues about the
diagnostic Cascade and somebody made a
comment well the patient would pay for
it but no not necessarily when they come
into their provider the diagnostic
Cascade would start getting billed to
the insurers the other thing is actually
it's simply the patient perception of
health and I have had patience with this
we I know this is not covering Imaging
but there was a very good Imaging study
done uh studied on in imaging using MRIs
on people who where the MRI was really
not even relevant to their issue which
showed degenerative change like having
gray hair and wrinkles but when they
read that if they were the study was you
either got the report or you didn't get
the report and the point is those who
read these nasty words like degenerative
and all those things which simply
implied normal age-related changes and
tested them later on their perceptions
of Wellness they viewed themselves as
not being well and I've had patients who
came in and because of a test which was
misinterpreted
itself they had that disease and changed
their behavior one was rheumatoid
arthritis other ones are Lyme disease
and so it is not a trivial issue in
terms of people uh trying to use Dr
Google for understanding the importance
of the meeting of a
um
of a test
particularly the screening tests and in
medical school we were taught you do a
history that gives you a great deal of
information that'll give you the
diagnosis then a physical exam
laboratory tests are almost always done
purely as a confirmatory or monitoring
or in some senses screening but we see
incredible amount of disagreement on the
United States preventative task force
when we come to screening issues and it
takes a lot of time to figure out what's
appropriate what isn't appropriate as a
screening test so I still see that there
is more chance for harm we have a
dysfunctional Health Care system I would
agree uh for example representative
Edwards should not have had that nine
months he didn't have health insurance
but this is a Band-Aid on a bad health
system that I think makes it even worse
thank you
representative NADA Upham oh thank you
thank you for listening to my comments
so um a lot of tests have become
available when I was a young woman you
had to go through your doctor to get a
pregnancy test you don't have to do that
now you can go to the pharmacy there
were several times I a mother of many
kids you know you worried they had strep
you had to go through the doctor's
office you had to bundle all four of
them up in the car to take the one
whatever so I I think there's a lot of
upside in people aiming being able to
order A1C tests strep tests
um I'm sure many of you could think of a
bunch of other tests it's like either
you've got it you're not so if I took my
child and they had strep then I take
them to the doctor to get medication
I had
uh a lot of time this weekend I called
my medical Posse my many friends that
are nurse practitioners and a few that
were doctors
um and they said yeah why not buyer
beware so I'm going to vote in favor of
thank you
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman
uh speak to the second of the motion on
the uh at the pass
initially when I saw this bill I was
opposed to it
um but upon research what I found out is
that as representative Marsh said before
patients today can go into many
locations throughout New Hampshire
and have the blood drawn and at that
point in time the blood leaves the state
and goes to another state that allows
for it to be processed
so this build is not really enfranchise
the patient to get the blood work done
it's just a question of where it gets
done
well basically at this point in time
what changed my mind with the bill was
saying wait a minute we have the ability
for a patient today to go into a drawing
Center have the blood withdrawn and then
it has to leave the state and go to
another facility outside the state so
all we're doing fundamentally is taking
the work that can be done here in New
Hampshire and sending it to another
state to get the work done so the
ability for the patient to get the lab
work and get the results and so forth
this build is not
Foster or does it basically um
permit it's already there all this does
is allow for the laboratory to be
located in New Hampshire to process the
work
thank you representative soloway
uh thank you Mr chairman
um of the 400 members of the New
Hampshire State House of Representatives
I would have to guess that 380 of them
have no medical expertise to speak of
whatsoever
um it is therefore my suggestion that we
keep our noses out of the practitioner
patient relationship where it simply
doesn't belong we have a system that
works there were no catastrophes out
there it seems to go along well
um and I would suggest that we mind our
own business and stay away from Bad
government
I've taken my hand down representative
Cushman thank you Mr chairman
um I just want to say that what I'm
hearing is patients don't know enough
they can't order their own labs they
don't have the expertise I I think we're
selling patients short very much
um I think patients especially those
with chronic illness do become experts
on their own conditions oftentimes
um I have encountered patients who went
misdiagnosed for years and I'm glad that
representative canark brought up Lyme
disease because that's one of the
diseases that often goes undiagnosed or
misdiagnosed because many Physicians are
unwilling to order the lab testing
um after a short course of antibiotics
which doesn't always take care of the
problem life can go and be chronic for
years so there are other Physicians who
will order these lab tests
um but it may be cost prohibitive or you
know maybe someone can't find a
physician who will do it but I I've
known patients who have had Lyme disease
for years and
um for chronic illness patients this
will be very convenient you know
especially those who have to have repeat
Labs drawn who maybe can't afford to go
in for a visit every time excuse me
every time or go to a lab
um
you know and have sorry every time they
have to go to the lab
um and they also become very
knowledgeable on their normal range
um for their lab values uh sometimes
Physicians will look at patient's lab
values and not understand that there's
something else going on I've had
patients who you know they know where
their normal lab range is and it may be
a little bit below normal and they're
getting over treated because their their
physician doesn't
um doesn't really acknowledge that
that's normal for them
um so I just think that we need to give
patients the reins over their health as
much as possible and nursing uh you know
it's it's a value that we have that when
patients are more responsible for their
health their outcomes are better so I
think we should give them as much
economy over their health as we can
uh thank you Mr chair
um a couple of points um I understand
that the the specific tests uh ha1c and
so forth uh the paintings really do get
well attuned to monitoring it themselves
um England was also an example of people
on coumadin uh they established a home
program and people had their blood uh
were able to monitor themselves people
on chronic coumadin and actually had
better compliance and better end result
and when patients did it themselves
however this instance uh Bill does not
identify any specific area this is
basically carte blanche
everything everything goes
um and that's the problem I have with it
um secondly
um there's the legal aspect
um they say well it says in here
um that the uh individual physician or
provider would not be held responsible
if they didn't order it
but if the patient calls the office and
says I had a test drawn you are now
obligated to respond
um if you're in a Health Care System
where that lab
is within an overall Healthcare network
with a common uh uh Health Care chart uh
automatically if there's an aberrant lab
it shows up and is addressed within
whatever office uh that patient normally
attends
um and as therefore there is a legal
obligation to respond
and in fact
New Hampshire is one of the few
states
that mandate nrsa
the standard to which Physicians and
Physicians I don't know about nurses
Physicians are held is the AMA guide to
ethical Behavior
and in that so that's the standard we're
met that we have to meet and be board to
uh to have our license
uh and in that in there it specifically
states that if you're aware of an
aberrant situation it's your
obligation
to respond that means you may call your
partner and say can you handle this for
me or call a consultant or whatever but
you can't ignore it so that's the
standard that we're held for our
licenses so for those reasons I I I I
kind of like the idea
I'll be people be taking responsibility
I love having patients that can do that
but I think this is this is goes a
little bit too far and just has some of
the other intent unintended consequences
that uh Dr konark has outlined as well
as the uh other ones that I've just
mentioned thank you
thank you Mr chairman um I I agree with
representative Cushman that I think
we're we're selling patients a little
short by assuming that they can't be
responsible with information from test
results having said that I think all of
the discussion as to the wisdom of
allowing patients to test to order their
own tests or not is actually moot
because they can as as representative
Marsh said when he introduced this they
already can so
um the the only practical implication of
this as I see it is whether or not we
want more jobs in the state of New
Hampshire or more jobs outside the state
of New Hampshire do we want to
strengthen businesses in New Hampshire
or not
um you know and I'm I'm open to hearing
uh why that might be wrong but that's
that's how it occurs to me at the moment
thank you the check calls on himself for
a couple of comments I talked to the
three pcps that are under my employee on
this and one of the things they said is
yes patients come in and present test
data
from wherever and of course we respond
to that and if we heard a patient call
in and say oh I ordered a test and here
it is would say make an appointment and
bring it in of course we're responsible
for that
then the second thing is
um numbers of our patients come in uh
very well uh read many of them very well
educated
um some of them get their education from
Dr Google or it's um uh younger brother
People magazine and so sure we've got a
number of people who come in who have
researched
what they believe or if they actually do
have is a symptom many of them are very
well educated and that can be helpful it
certainly means the patient is taking
responsibility for his or all her own
Medical Care and the ones that come in
uh who are have a lot of information
much of which is bogus these are pretty
much our patients who if they didn't
research it they wouldn't believe what
the doctor told them anyway
so the conclusion that my three pcps
so I'm certainly going to be supporting
the bill and the other comments or
representative gay thank you for taking
my comments I'm one of those I'm one of
those patients like you describe it'll I
read up everything I can and ultimately
we patients have to decide who to go to
I had to go to three spinal surgeons
before I got one who actually believed
the MRI report that was written by by a
doctor at the uh
Baptist Hospital you know very famous I
had two doctors who didn't believe it
and so I didn't feel comfortable I kept
going I don't think I'm unique in that I
feel I evaluate what that doctor tells
me and there's no way that a person can
go get a blood test or any kind of test
and treat themselves they still have to
go to a doctor
if they want to get uh medications
ordered or treatments ordered so it's
still a partnership uh it's kind of um
it's kind of paternalistic to be told
that as patients we're not supposed to
be uh
kept as aware of possible of our own
medical condition you know it is a
partnership and uh we we have to hold
our own
so I certainly think this is a great
deal I'm certain representative gay one
of the spinal surgeons with whom you had
I thought he would really listen to that
statement though that's so personal no
they were down here from this end of the
state yes
anyone else with something to say share
ask
saying nothing
the question before us is House Bill 381
FM relative to Laboratory Testing
the motion is ought to pass made by
representative Marsh and seconded by
representative Merchant would the clerk
please call the roll
thank you chairman Pearson
representative Marsh yes representative
McMahon yes representative Nelson yes
representative Acton yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Alexander yes
representative King yes representative
cofult yes
representative Weber
no
representative McKay no
okay yes okay there he is got stubborn
again
you I'm sorry can you repeat your vote
Yes
representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro no
representative Woods no representative
Merchant yes
14 yay 7 news and representative Marsh
if you would write the committee report
and who would like to write The Minority
Report
it doesn't have to be one
in our Kansas family
representative knurka has a hand up
representative canark would you like to
unmute
I stuck up for you a minute ago so come
on here hurry up buddy so you're going
to write The Minority Report
thank you
this concludes the exact session at
hospitals 381 and Begins the Lunch
you can choose six times
I'll be back in 20 minutes perhaps time
that's a good idea
foreign
are we live and in person
yeah I can hear you talking
ah Kim how are you good
you're you're my future room is not
Sharon the room will have to be unmuted
I just currently muted oh perfect there
we go okay
I should you should add to your list of
tough graduates myself
oh yes oh I'm perfectly aware but more
than that you are my role model because
if I want to go to age 90 in the house
of course everybody's listening to our
conversation
I haven't said anything criminal yet not
yet
okay
foreign
[Music]
I got my inoculation today anybody who
hasn't had it you have nothing to fear
there's no pain and it's several hours
later and I don't feel a thing
foreign
[Music]
have to wait any length of time Jim
about 10 minutes wow because they said
they had three and four hour Waits the
first day well we went up to Sears we've
had both of our shots we got the second
shot Pfizer shot uh what about 10 10
yeah about 10 days ago now
um and they were they were really well
organized uh I mean I mean really very
very efficient new everything got us
through
um and neither one of us had any side
effects for either one I was very
impressed but so I've got my old number
plate which has me is
chairman of Health and Human Services
something around it so the guy came and
he said where you've sent here to check
those license plates Jim are very valued
looking out here they are so what I've
said was if they sent me to check on you
the response would be that you're doing
a wonderful job
congratulations Jim yeah
you can probably put that in the paper
yeah
it's a marvelous experience yeah because
I was nervous going in to be honest
about it it was me my fire alarm was
about it's not going off so I have to
put a finger pointing to tell you on the
other side Jen yeah
okay we gotta get back it's almost one
o'clock somewhere and
um I am now reopening the hearing of
House Bill
103 which has to do with establishing a
dental benefit
and you should have received on the 3rd
of March a revised footnote and my uh
advisor tells me that there's no vote
needed it's just an updated fiscal Mount
sorry this come out is it's operative is
March 3rd and so now the hearing is open
again on the dental benefit and I the
chair calls on
can you hear me yeah okay well first of
all thank you all for your service to
the state and representative McKay I'm
um I'm not I haven't yet gotten it but
I'm sure it will be as good as you uh
suggested so I'm Tom rafio president CEO
of Northeast Dela Dental I know I know
most of you and of course this bill is
you know similar to HB 250 last session
which like many things in 2020 didn't
make it over
um the Finish Line Northeast Delta
Dental we are not non-profit but the
largest dental benefits insurer in the
state we have one Mission only and
that's to improve the oral health and
access to dental care
for everyone so our new tagline is
everybody deserves a healthy smile
not just people with traditional dental
coverage like yourself if you have it
through Delta Dental and we have
probably 60 to 70 percent of the
Employers in this beautiful state have
our coverage and many many
individuals have it through our private
exchange or healthcare.gov but everybody
deserves a healthy smile and so
um HB 103 Builds on the important work
of the work group that was enacted in
law in 2019 to create an implementation
plan I of course understand that the
Senate bill Senate Bill 150 which passed
out of the Senate with a 5-0 vote and
will be voted on by the full Senate this
Thursday
this bill is consistent with that and I
understand that there may be an
amendment to uh you know make it even
more can make the two bills even more
consistent that's correct so
implementation date I mean I've been uh
I've been at this literally I came to
New Hampshire in 1995 and have been
talking about this issue literally now
for a quarter quarter or a century and I
was hoping that in my professional
lifetime that this could actually happen
and I think it would have uh already
perhaps you know short of the uh shorter
of the pandemic but now it's uh now we
have this a great opportunity
um to make it happen even if it's not
implemented until 2023 we have to keep
the ball moving forward it'll increase
the employability of many working New
Hampshire adults
um and and we've given you all these
stats but it will save on emergency room
costs
um there's there's a lot of studies out
there which suggest and we're very
conservative here but it'll also Save A
Lot on the medical side there's so much
interrelationship between a lot of
conditions and so in the in the long run
there'll probably be savings on on the
medical side so we really need to
continue the progress and then move this
move this forward I want to urge the
committee to pass HB 103 and that
amendment that I I think will happen is
fine with us we thank representative
Shapiro for bringing forth this
legislation and all of you for staying
the course
um the mouth is part of the body you
can't have good overall health without
good oral health well in the long run
save the state money get more people
employed and everybody deserves a
healthy smile and let's make this happen
we're we're in sync with the New
Hampshire Dental Society with the with
with the Department everybody that's uh
has a concern about oral health is on on
the same page here so please please
let's let's make this happen and I'm
happy to answer any specific question on
you know on on costs or or
implementation or Delta Dental's role
any questions for Tom Raphael
sorry
[Music]
representative Woods
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Raphael for taking my question uh do you
have any studies uh from the dental
perspective of the exact uh economic
impact of improved oral health
um uh um do you have anything available
yeah we and we I mean the Department's
had a lot of that my actuary Courtney
Warren has been on the work group
there's a famous study called the Wakely
study which is relatively new which gets
into the the bet the benefit of the
value proposition so I think the
committee representative Woods has all
that but we can certainly uh send you
yeah
uh secondly uh this is sort of a signed
question uh do you know if from the
dental perspective that they're working
uh with other agencies like the American
Medical Association uh to collaborate in
terms of uh uh efforts to incorporate
dental health and to General Health
Plans
that's that's a a great question that's
what that's what my life proposition is
about more and more Physicians and
dentists are cooperating there's more
and more uh cooperation between medical
schools and dental schools between
pediatricians and dentists so we are we
are working towards that
um there's a great book called teeth by
Mary Otto that I encourage you all if
you get a chance to read and really gets
into you know the the direction of the
country on this we've come a long way it
explains why originally the head was
separated from the body but we all now
know
um that you that we have to connect
ahead Dental Health mental health with
everything and so I encourage you to if
you get an opportunity to read a book
called teeth by Mary Otto it'll get into
a lot of uh the macro question that
representative Woods asked
thank you thank you
well thank you and let's make it happen
thank you thank you so much the chair
calls
michaelberg from the United Way of
Greater Nashua
uh yes good afternoon I presume you can
hear me all right we can hear you all
right yes good afternoon my name is Mike
gaffelburg I'm the president of the
United Way of Greater Nashua and I'm
coming here today
um to you in support of HB 103
establishing that New Hampshire Medicaid
programs be expanded to include a
substantial Dental benefit
as an organization we are strong
supporters of the greater Nashua Dental
Connection providing access to Dental
Care high quality dental care for
low-income residents recognizing of
course the value of dental care and the
overall health of our community
we all know that good dental health and
oral hygiene is of critical importance
in fact many people often are surprised
to learn that the number one cause
other than a pandemic the number one
cause for a young person to miss a day
of school is still an untreated
toothache
as an adult you don't have to have good
dental coverage if you don't have good
dental coverage your muscle much less
likely to undertake preventive care such
as annual screenings and cleanings if
you're also you're also much more likely
to get have small issues such as routine
carriers or periodontists periodontists
become more serious issues requiring
extensive procedures like extractions or
gingivectomies oftentimes lacking dental
insurance means that these procedures
become emergency room procedures much
more expensive to treat reactive Dental
approaches can also lead to significant
pain which in turn can result in
addiction to pain medications
poor oral health can easily result in
other negative consequences affecting a
person's employability and Mental Health
Data shows that a strong Community
return on investment for good dental
care and demonstrates that dental health
is a significant determinant in overall
health for all of these reasons we would
strongly endorse HP 103 and encourage
you to pass it with a recommendation
thank you
and that exhausts the list of people
that I have who have signed up by the
deadline to testify
I didn't have my oh I'm sorry I didn't
not a problem
I see no further people testifying and
no questions and we are waiting
um
sorry
an amendment has just been sent to the
committee relevant to this bill and I'm
hoping hard copy will come down to us on
ready
thank you may I suggest we take a
five-minute recess of people to look at
the amendment that we just sent out and
that Betty representative
sounds like a plan all around am I right
in thinking that the amendment is
just so we've got the right
I didn't hear that zero the amendment is
Adventure
and we're just curious for that to come
down
Mr chairman I don't think that's been
sent out to the committee the last one I
have from representative from Ms forcier
is 0678 and that's house bill 503. it
came from Bill Marsh
it
115 from Bill Marsh who says forwarded
okay I'll check I just received it about
six minutes ago yeah I I have it in hand
right here and printed wow could you cut
could you hand me one
now you ever have my copy thank you
well I have 9
684 amendments from representative Marsh
but not this one but that probably means
that Comcast has eaten it oh there it is
[Music]
can I ask a question though although we
said we take time to look at it one
thing that will guide us is if we know
what things are different for example
I'm looking at uh lines three through
nine and there they seem to be quite
similar if not the same as lines 13 to
19 at the original bill could you
identify what parts are different so we
can focus our attention on the different
parts and are we actually in the
executive session yet we shouldn't we're
moving that way no he has to open an
executive session yet what this bill
does is it makes the statutory
Department
150 as amended by zero six one two s
so the uh
two final sections of the bill are where
the changes are I'll go okay changes
when we introduce the amendment
but but since we're supposed to spend
five minutes looking at it be helpful if
we know where to look is it can you just
tell us what page what lines are
different
I think there are a few things one is
that it changes the date of
implementation which is on line 25 on
the first page
it also aligns the actual benefits
on the second page the lower part of the
second page to be aligned with Senate
Bill 150 and the current um what what
lines it helps much if I know what line
14 on page two okay thank you
yep
and um so it aligns the actual benefits
it changes the implementation date and
it makes clear that at some point this
will be merged with the children's
um
schedule program
okay
[Applause]
foreign
yes
on the amendment on page two
on line six
it doesn't have a deadline or time frame
for the state to modify the state plan
with Medicare medicide Medicaid
which it refers back to the date of
implementation it says within the
quarter of the Year within the three
months of the date of implementation
those of you in the room uh committee
service just said the amendment's being
run down here
[Music]
no just to make it formal I'm going to
and Hospital 103.
did you actually credit here
we can certainly discuss it I just
I
hope
the exception on 103. so we can discuss
this
well I would move if we adopt Amendment
zero six eight eight
I will second that okay and we're going
to wait we can discuss that while some
of us are waiting for it
[Music]
so I think I already said this but
um people didn't hear it or people
didn't have the amendment in front of
them I think this amendment does a few
things
um one it aligns
House Bill 103 with Senate bill
one five zero which has just been passed
out of Health and Human Services in the
Senate by uh five to zero vote ought to
pass
so it really makes these identical bills
and one of the things it does is it
changes the date of implementation to
January 1st 2023
it also takes the language about the
actual benefits it doesn't really change
what the benefits are but it takes the
language about the actual benefits on
page two line 14 to line 20 and makes
those identical with the Senate bill and
also aligns them with the working group
in DHHS about what they've based their
estimates on
the other thing it does is makes clear
that this will eventually be merged the
Children's Dental benefit to try to put
it all into one program to affect cost
savings
so um representative Marsh can add
something if there's more but I that
those are the major changes that this
amendment makes
uh I would I would agree with that and I
would point out that some of those
changes were made so that we can
actually do it for our physical
environment and that is something that's
important to me because I try to be
responsible uh and so so that was my
major objection before it didn't have an
Actuarial note but now we have a good
Actuarial data that we've received just
for the last few days both from the
state and fiscal note and from uh Delta
Dental and the Actuarial nails and that
persuades me that this is a reasonable
time
one additional thing about the amendment
and pushing the data out further which
pains me to tell you the truth January
1st 2023 seems like a long ways away but
the estimates that the
um
Dental benefit working group and DHHS
made
um Were Meant to
look forward to a time after
covid so that the um
that the numbers of people on a Medicaid
which have been which have swollen
during the pandemic would go back down
to a more normal
um numbers and therefore it would be
more affordable to have the benefit
representative gay has something to
share
well actually it was a question
you probably both answered it
financially you're afraid of adding this
expense right now uh but 23 SM do you
ever do it like six months before 23 or
yeah I also don't want to make things
super expensive but
I'll bet you have cost analysis gonna
Shuffle that we're paying out a lot for
medical costs and dental care is not
provided
I'm assuming y'all did this painfully
but I really don't like to have to wait
till 23 January 23 either
I can speak to that I am completely with
you
um
however one of the things I've learned
is that there's an awful lot of moving
parts to anything but specifically to
this and there's a lot of people
involved and there's the Senate and
there's the house and there's the
working group and um
you know my interest is in it eventually
happening and I think this is what we
had to do to work with all the other
people who are working on this to make
we would rather not get in the way of
that process so this is just us
endorsing what uh they've done the
Senate and uh coming up board and said
yes we would like to see this happen
please
[Music]
anyone else with something to share or
um representative so um did I hear you
say the Senate just passed this five to
zero
their Canadians that has not gone to the
fourth right just the uh their committee
there right that's correct yes thank you
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman
um on the fiscal note
moving it out to 2023
how does it impact a fiscal note is it
favorable unfavorable or it doesn't make
I think it's I think it's favorable
because the
um the numbers of people on Medicaid
right now are inflated due to the
coronavirus and it is assumed although I
learned that we can't assume anything
about the virus
um that those numbers will go down as
the virus recedes and more people go to
work and more people are insured in
other ways
this is on the amendment
0-688h which we've got now in the room
and it was moved by representative
Shapiro and seconded by representative
Marsh this amendment will make the bill
equal to the Senate's equivalent
seeing none when the clock is ready
would you call the roll please on
Amendment zero six eight eight H to
House Bill 103 moved by representative
Shapiro and seconded by representative
Marsh
thank you Mr chairman representative
uh representative Nelson yes
representative
Acton yes representative gay yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Olson yes representative
Alexander
representative King yes representative
Co Falls
yes
representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative snow yes
representative Clerk
yes
representative Solway yes representative
Cannon yes representative Netter Upham
yes representative Shapiro
yes yes
representative Woods yes
representative Pearson yes
the bill passes 22 minutes
thank you the amendment passes
28-0 and the chair now calls on
as much as it pains me to do this I am
going to move that we retain House Bill
um
I don't know if there's a second
second
um can I speak to this yes you may okay
as I mentioned before for our
um an enormous number of people involved
in this and a number of there's two
different bills
um and there are there's the fact that
money has not
was not in the governor's budget
initially
and so there are a lot of moving parts
and I have done my best to be in touch
with
um
Senator Rosenwald who sponsored the bill
in the Senate the people in the working
group representative Marsh who's seems
to be a conduit to representative
Bradley and um Senators
um in the majority
um
and I think there are a lot of
um positive signs at this point
um the working group has come up with a
list of benefits
um
the um Financial
um note was 7.4 million dollars per year
and Delta Dental came in with an
estimate that was
um less than that although they weren't
comparing exactly the same things
um
representative Pearson has told me that
the um house
um
the house finance committee is looking
for what our health care priorities and
that he has informed them that a dental
benefit is a priority
um
so there's a lot of things that are
looking very positive but we all know
that this has never really happened
so the reason I am making a motion to
retain this
is that
there seems to be a
um there seems to be a group of people
in the Senate who are coalescing around
a plan to
um
put the money into the budget in the
Senate and put the policy into the
budget in the Senate maybe including
table in the Senate bill but in any case
making it a reality
um
second thing is that I've been informed
by
um
representative walner that
if our bill goes to the house and gets
defeated it will be very difficult for
our party
maybe both parties to advocate
for putting this money in the budget in
the finance committee
it would make it much more difficult for
them to say that the house endorses this
idea
um thirdly by retaining this bill if a
dental benefit does not get put into the
budget does not get put into the house
bill too
then we have a bill that's aligned with
the work that's already been done and is
ready to go for next year
so I feel very
um I feel very badly about asking you to
retain this bill that I've worked really
hard on and a lot of people have worked
really hard on but I think it's the
logical strategic choice for the moment
foreign
response
representative Marsh yes I thank
representative Senator Shapiro for that
and uh uh I was thinking along those
same lines until very recently
at this point in time it does look to me
like the stars are aligning and that the
money is going to actually be there to
get this done
um and that our committee pessimists may
be the emphasis to push the Senate bill
over the finish line so uh I personally
would like to see a motion uh not the
passes amended motion before we retain
Nation but if that's the world with many
to otherwise I respect
could I have a can I have a point of
thank you I'm I'm having a hard time
hearing representative Marsh there's an
echo so
um
were you asking us to do a motion of
ought to pass and then retain it no oh
good because if we if we move on to pass
and it passes it's it's out of our hands
so unless somebody moves to reconsider
uh so am I right in thinking that you
are also in favor of retaining at this
point uh no when I said is that I would
so you would like to pass it straight
out onto the house floor
and what would be if that if the house
doesn't go along with us what happens
then that is the problem
yeah
I I'm I so what
what was it that changed because I'm
trying to get wrapped my mind around the
fact that there have been a gazillion
negotiations on this and a gazillion
concessions made in all kinds of
different directions and suddenly
um we're getting
I understand that but I think we finally
got the financial analysis that we asked
for
I mean I I I'd be delighted to pass the
thing I'm just I'm just concerned about
um representations that have been made
to people who are not in this room
that's all
foreign
thank you Mr chairman
um I I have uh listened with uh I dare I
say some confusion to the representative
from Keen for whom I have the highest
highest respect
um and I've heard his ambivalent
feelings about
um asking to retain this bill I also
heard him indicate that there was
movement in the Senate but he suggested
that the Senate was likely to table this
motion so I I have some confusion there
I've also listened to the representative
from Brookfield for whom I have equal
respect uh who says that the numbers are
now in place further looking at the
state revenues that are coming in it is
very likely that to my surprise we will
have the budget available to fund this
program we all agree that the program is
of extraordinary value I must tell you
I've worked on this topic for five years
now it is time it's time to make this
move forward and there's a cost savings
built into it we need to take the leap
it's an act of Courage please let us
defeat uh the retention and pass this
bill
and if I may Mr Mr chairman just speak
to the table
in the Senate
administer
[Music]
just go ahead
go ahead represent Weber
uh what the Senate usually does their
their process on
sometimes tracking ours but often not
tracking ours with bills that contain a
a fiscal impact is they will pass them
on their floor and then they will table
them and just leave them on the table uh
but it's it's not the equivalent to
retention but that is a procedure that
they follow regularly with many many
bills that's how they get things into
the budget they don't they don't pass
the Bill itself which would
absolutely required gets into the budget
they they view it more as a statement of
policy that the the bodies adopted
um that having been said if if it's the
will of the committee to go ahead and
vote this ought to pass I'm certainly
representative Canuck
thank you yes I I very much want to see
this past too but I I recognize the
strategy and I if we do have things
moving in the Senate including putting
it into the uh budget I think keeping
this in our back pocket as a bill which
we will have retained gives us that
ability to come back in the next uh year
if perchance it somehow implodes and
doesn't happen and I think that the
arguments that were made by
representative Shapiro regarding the
it might be more difficult to push it
along if the if the house is taking a
position against it makes it a little
bit more difficult to
to just move ahead with with a ought to
pass because of the fact that it I can
see some downsides of how it might cause
trouble and I can't see any downside of
holding back if the Senate is going full
steam ahead including in the budget and
there's an upside of holding it in
retention to give us that fallback
position should we need it so I kind of
Mr chairman representative Merchant
Shakira
I'm looking at the amendment that we
just passed in the amendment
the date of the contract to take effect
is January 2023.
so if we do retain this
and we act on it next year
we're still not going to impact the
that would be correct we could pass it
in the exact form of the phone
so again strategically speaking if
things don't materialize either in the
Senate are in House Bill 2 we can
revisit this if we retain it instead of
is that correct I didn't understand your
question well basically if we we came
the bill
as as it's amended
and the Senate doesn't act on it or
doesn't go into House Bill 2 which is
the budget
we could next year pull it off the
retaining act on the bill and still hit
the January 2023 implementation date
that's a very effective argument
representative and it's not in the
budget because the budget was passed
this year correct
I think that's I think that's
undetermined
um because
we don't know what will happen if we
have to submit this bill again next year
we don't know what the numbers will be
we don't know what
I think that it's possible that the
implementation date could be the same
but
thank you
I had a nice chat with representative
Weiler head of house finance and
convinced him of the
the wise economics and The Frugal
economics of doing the right thing it's
one of those occasions that we love when
doing the right thing for people is also
cost effective and he heard that
argument he received that argument what
he does next is up to him we've had a
good discussion and he said he took my
point representative Weber
um that's a residual I'm sorry
yes um
[Music]
I am as I said I was extremely
ambivalent about asking to retain this
and now I'm a little bit
I'm more than a little bit I'm surprised
by representative Marsh's suggestion
that we not retain it since
um part of my decision only one part was
came out of discussions with
representative Marsh and um
his suggestion that would retain it or
his
um passing on suggestions from the
Senate that we retain it so
I am completely baffled
um certainly emotionally I would like to
see it go forward and pass
um
so
what am I trying to say besides that I'm
confused I guess one thing that I don't
know that there's an answer to but
um
I would ask
um representative Marsh and maybe
representative Pearson as well what your
thoughts are
um
on what will happen if this goes to the
house I mean it is I am certain that the
Democratic caucus will support this
wholeheartedly
um
and so I'm really asking I don't know if
this is exactly appropriate if you have
any sense of what the Republican caucus
will and Leadership will do in terms of
supporting this bill should it go to the
all I know to answer that representative
Shapiro is I have spoken to numbers of
my Republican colleagues who
listen to me at least
and I believe I am making an effective
case for this and would speak for it but
representative Marsh is not in
affirmatively yeah how sessions seem to
be attendance driven at this point in
time and uh I don't think any of us know
what the attendance hope is again uh
it's one of those high risk higher
rewards versus the safer situation we go
debate a very effective argument
representative yeah
[Music]
so could I suggest a Way Forward
calling the question
could I suggest a Way Forward Mr Mr
chairman
I would like to suggest
please do
it it seems to me on the basis of the
current discussion that if the maker of
the motion and the seconder of the
motion wish to withdraw we could
withdraw this motion and another motion
could be made otherwise we are going to
have to vote on the motion to retain and
I I will just state that I have heard
enough that I will I will now vote
against the motion to retain so another
motion can be brought
this is a question that goes
this is a question that goes to
Representatives Shapiro and Cushman if
they are willing to withdraw and if
they're not that's perfectly their
um
I will withdraw the motion and let the
committee decide on whether to send it
to the house or not
well
it's going to be the same outcome either
way
it's going to either be
paid or
attention yeah so so I'm fine with
withdrawing okay representative Cushman
withdraws and so there is now no motion
on the floor representative Weber do you
care to make a motion no I don't care to
make a motion I I think that somebody
who has worked on the bill should make a
motion
yes
sure my question what's the downside of
retention
yes you may uh
I want to thank representative Alexander
in the realm of reality and he pointed
out to me that a certain bill that we
discussed at the last house session
and this could very well go the same way
and that could be distinctly
disadvantageous
can't stop being this convinced me and
therefore I will make a motion to retain
quick to jump in so Marsh and Cushman
now do you have enough paper over there
clerk
um
we passed the amendment 27. so the
motion
um now before us and I really hope
there's no more discussion
um
is to move to retain now move by Martian
seconded by Cushman on houseville 103 as
amended by zero six eight eight
and would the clerk please call can I
can I have a point of order point of
orders acceptable
um
I in no way want to complain about
representative Marsh wearing a mask I
completely endorse is wearing a mask but
I couldn't understand what he said when
he all of a sudden made another motion
to retain it representative Shapiro I
heard of this business and not personal
thank you representative I would not be
in this building without my n95 mask
manufactured in the state of New
Hampshire which I think got to be made
but I want to thank representative
Alexander who called me to my census and
pointed out several realities and this
is certainly the Safe Way Forward as you
correctly pointed out
it's always nice when the census works
out
the motion on the floor with the clerk
please now call the roll
thank you chairman I think
um representative Marsh that's yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes
representative Acton yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Alexander yes
representative King yes representative
Koval yes representative Weber
with great confusion representative
Weber votes yes
representative McKay no
representative snow yes
representative nurse
uh representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter upon yes
representative Shapiro
yes
representative Woods yes Representatives
Merchants yes
representative Pearson
yes 19 yes to no he does not need
or
um
it's just in from our viewing audience
uh I have been reminded that one does
not move the question in committee
so when I moved that
question I shouldn't have so apologies
and
we are
so we are retained
and this ends the executive session on
how students
and we will now begin the exact session
on House Bill 503
and it is the codifying the Council on
housing stability ah yes
well having fun shout no several times
it's nice to hear the other work too
thank you
um representative Shapiro sets aside his
amendments
0379h and zero four six four h
and there is an amendment that I have in
my possession zero six three four of
March 4th but just hot off the press is
the amendment zero six seven eight H sh
Shapiro and Marsh so I need to know
about
um
the previous
amendments which is zero six three
4 by Martian Shapiro is that the one you
wish us to deal with or another one
representative Marsh yes uh Mr chairman
I'll move Amendment zero six seven eight
eight and I will speak to my emotions
all right
second
thank you Mr chair the difference
between the two amendments is a single
word on page two line 17 where we change
the word mental to the word behavioral
to accurately reflect the name of the
association
oh got it that's it that's the
difference between the two amendments
what this does is it uh converges uh the
intent of the original bill into the
existing Council which we were told by
the department will be duplicative so
that the uh issues that we have to be
addressed will be addressed faster and
will continue to be addressed on an
ongoing basis because the council has no
thank you
any questions on the amendment to
for even higher than normal wait time I
wanted to remind me that all of your
current account information is available
the motion is on
Amendment zero six seven eight
to House Bill
503 moved by March seconded by the chair
and the clerk may call the role thank
you Mr chairman representative Marsh yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Acton yes representative gay yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Folsom yes representative
Alexander yes
representative King yes representative
co-fault yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative snow yes representative
yes
representative Solway yes
representative Cannon yes representative
Netter Upham yes representative Shapiro
yes
representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Pearson yes 21-0
21-0 representative Shapiro do you have
a motion now
I would defer to representative Marsh
okay
thank you representative Shapiro I was
going to defer to you because it's your
bill but if it's really great I'll be
glad to make the motion but but because
it's your bill I I would be uh very
you don't seem to want to well it was
not my bill initially
no I thought your name was on in that
case I will move on to pass as amended
uh house still 503 there's amendment
number zero six seven eight
no no second discussion
we have to have a second I was like a
representative Solway uh thank you Mr
chairman
um uh I would like to speak against the
motion first of all I'd like to praise
uh the representative from Manchester
for his compassion in dealing with the
issue of homelessness
um I have spoken with him about this
privately and I certainly feel that his
heart and mind as usual are in the right
place
however I was warned by a previous
chairman of this committee the
representative from Walpole that the
state has numerous numerous commissions
which typically don't get an awful lot
done
creating a new commission is going to
pull together numbers of people
representing political constituencies
which is the manner of such commissions
such as for example somebody from the
medical society somebody from the
nursing association somebody from ACLU
oh no I take that away
um legal defense I don't know uh numbers
of political constituencies that will
come together none of whom necessarily
has substantial expertise in the area in
question we have a commission on housing
stability and my friends I would like to
point out to you that within the state
of New Hampshire we have not one but two
nationally recognized experts on
homelessness
homelessness in the urban communities
is best represented by our own uh
representative from New Market may I
name her Mr chairman
I know it's not uh normally done yes you
may uh representative Charlotte
dilorenzo is one of the founding uh
members of the Pine Street Inn in Boston
and is extremely well versed in issues
of urban homelessness at the same time
at Salem State College is uh rep is uh
Professor Yvonne missing a resident of
Chester New Hampshire who was the author
of the book out of sight out of mind
homelessness in small town America which
speaks to the issues of rural
homelessness we have these two people
just within our midst who would be who
put together in the same room for two
hours could write a report with an
action statement appended that would
make a great deal of sense I believe
members of this committee that um
created yet another commission is not
the most effective way to deal with
homelessness I believe that we should
remand it to uh the the commission on
housing stability with our instruction
that they confer with uh professor
vissing and representative De Lorenzo
for their help in coming up with a plan
for homelessness in New Hampshire and I
you may respond representative Marsh
thank you representative Solomon
um I want to say that I agree with you
entirely and I will point out that the
motion on the floor does not create a
new commission what it does is it sends
the issue of Housing and homelessness
back to the Council on housing stability
it expands their already existing duty
to address the issue of homelessness
with some of the concerns raised by the
initial bill and adds a few members to
the commission to uh were thought to be
uh interested in an important in dealing
with the problem so we are not creating
a new commission by the motion currently
on the poor we are remaining it to the
new Council on housing stability which
yeah
anyone else representative gay uh yeah I
guess thank you for taking my question
it really is uh the problem with the
wording is that on 14 line 14 of page
one of the amendment that it says would
count on housing stability established
maybe established is it the word uh made
permanent expanded uh might be more
accurate and uh certainly we were some
of us you can speak for himself another
member on this committee we were very
impressed with
um Representatives
um
I'll shoot down for long last
he was commending organizations that
have boots on the ground who have a
track record it's not just higher-ups
planning things it was that maybe you
could finish this conversation could I
give my time to him
sure go ahead all right um yeah I was I
was impressed with the presentation that
was made last week
um and
the the people that are part of this uh
this house bill
are people that are involved in the
community and they're involved in their
areas and so I think that uh the boots
on the ground is
um is just what we need uh you know to
to representative uh salaries we need we
don't need another person or another
um bureaucratic
committee that's actually uh telling us
what what to do without having any kind
of representation out on the streets so
I I that's one reason why I like this
bill
anyone else
point of information Mr who's Mr
chairman you are recognized
um I'm I'm wondering if we're my
understanding oh we were talking the
bill has been amended
so the the bill is now my understanding
is that the
um
Amendment replaces the bill in its
entirety is that correct yes
okay
um I I just wanted to be sure that we
were all in the same place and and it is
a for my further understanding that what
this has done is taken an existing
Council which was established by the
governor
and is now giving it the authority of
Statute and the
um blessing of the legislature and is
putting a few more members on it and is
directing it to address the homelessness
issue specifically instead of just
peripherally is that correct that is
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman again I think
representative Weber kind of spoke to it
but looking at the additional members
that are on page two
line 31 on those are the members I
believe that the represent LeBlanc spoke
to and the other people who addressed
this committee were talking about boots
on the ground that's where they're
coming from from those membership is
for me the amendment is set up the
initial section are the ones that were
originally put in by the governor's
order and then the second section is the
ones that we are adding uh which are not
duplicative of members in the first
section
so those would start on page two align
31. correct thank you
so we so we are basically adding what I
call boots on the ground people who are
in the homeless
Arena added if you will to the existing
Council
that's correct thank you
your muted can
hello
how's that am I I'm muted now hey am I
unmuted
thank you
I was hoping I could speak to
representative long we did get a I did
get a message from the mayor of
Manchester who's quite concerned about
the original construction of this
Committee of Housing and because it was
really a the original committee as set
up by the governor was really not
looking at homelessness at all it was
looking at Workforce housing and having
affordable housing for people with
business and opportunities expanded and
very little attention being given to
homelessness had a strong feeling it was
going to be swept under and I think this
is a particular concern in certain
communities at least Manchester and
Nashville are the big cities where
they've become kind of a magnet the
large numbers of homeless people and
during the covid-19
um event
you know the restrictions on the
existing shelters and so forth it's
becoming a gigantic problem and you've
seen it in the papers with tent cities
having to be broken up and so forth and
so on and we would just I think
everybody was concerned that this
committee is originally set up
it had people from mental health and
Health and Human Services but they were
all really bureaucrats that do not have
their feet in the ground to doing it
it's expanded unfortunately I don't have
a recent version of the bill so I don't
have a complete list of where it goes
but I do remember seeing it and that
certainly is better I would feel a lot
more comfortable about it if it's like
Finance was divided into two separate
divisions one on housing
you know one on housing stability is
they said before in Workforce housing
and the other on homelessness it could
also be one committee but to have two
divisions and I'm terribly afraid the
way it's constructed right now the issue
of homelessness is going to be an
afterthought and not much attention is
paid and I see it as a gigantic problem
here in Manchester I wish is do you know
as the sponsor of the bill is
representative along on the list to
testify today or not this is an
executive session but did he sign in to
be president for the executive session
I'd love to find out if anything has
changed with the mayor and others I was
hoping to see him at this noon meeting
and I didn't get a chance to leave on
time to do it
um but I have real concerns about this
the the this bill is going to do very
little about that other side and I think
representative long is not on this
meeting in any way
I understand but he's titled at 10. I
mean he can sit in his apartment he is
but he hasn't yeah he hasn't thank you
yes
um thank you Mr chairman I think
I would agree with some of the
sentiments that people have about this
being
um less than an ideal solution
um
305. I think that the Council on housing
instability as it will be set up if this
passes we'll have
um
any tasks and many many people including
um the
um membership which will be heavily
weighted in terms of government
um
someone used the word bureaucrats that's
um maybe got a negative connotation but
it it's weighted in terms of people in
state departments
so I think it's got like that it's got
it's far from ideal but when it's like
DHHS said that
um testified against
having uh how uh hopelessness Commission
I guess I thought that the commission
was doomed and that this
um was a compromise would at least
increase the membership and
to include the people that were in
representative Long's initial bill
so I hope that
um on the council they will take the
initiative to
um
give way to the homelessness problem and
maybe divide themselves into
um subgroups
representative soloway uh thank you Mr
chairman
um I would like to amplify on uh the
representative from Manchester's
comments and the representatives from
both of which I think are very well
taken however if you look at the
construction of such commissions they
have a decidedly Urban Focus here in New
Hampshire we also have a rural
homelessness problem which I think is
not being addressed in the legislation
if you go back to uh the book out of
sight out of mind and you go through
there's a also a documentary film that
accompanies it
um
if any of you have had the opportunity
to drive down a dirt road in New
Hampshire
and at the end of that road you find a
foundation of a home
with no home on top of it plywood boards
across the top and people living in the
basement of what was supposed to be a
home if you drive down that dirt road
and you find an old RV and there's
people living in it through the winter
if you find a tent camper with people
and their kids trying to survive the
winter those people are not addressed in
a commission that has an urban Focus
this problem might be better addressed
just by having DHHS
write a Consulting contract for people
like professor vissing and
representative De Lorenzo I think that
we're creating
yes a bureaucratic morass that's not
going to give us a concise directive
solution
thank you Mr chairman thank you
I'm withdrew but partly it was more of a
complaint there was so much
just like somebody else's voices is
being broadcast
simultaneously and I can hear it right
now so I don't know what you can do
about it but it was more of a complaint
that it's hard to hear yeah it's it's
somebody has a something in the
background can it often comes from you
could you mute yourself and see if it
foreign
anyone else with a hand up
thanks Ken
I don't think he ever took it down
representative guy
thank you for taking my question I
really am in question mode now because
it seems like we're all in agreement
that there's a serious housing problem
in the state both Rural and in uh cities
that needs to be addressed and we just
haven't found a way that we think is the
best way to put a group together
my my real question is that there could
be an appointment
I don't know if that's called ad hocs
but an appointment of people who are
experienced which would be named in the
bill in the representative lost bill and
if more people have been mentioned who
have professional who have a long track
record of addressing homelessness
I'm I'm so sorry that we are up against
the deadline because it sounds like
we're all concerned we're all aware we
have great ideas and how to put them
together do we have to pass a bill to do
that I also have serious reservations as
soon as these two groups of people were
combined into one because their their
concerns really are Divergent yes they
all need housing
but just getting housing doesn't solve
you know how do you get housing to
people who don't have money or have
mental issues it's not the same as
making affordable housing for people who
are working
so
you know again I want us to do something
but what is the best way is this amended
um
Council gonna do it or should we be
yeah sure
um there are there are mechanisms for
example the person who representative
saloway has mentioned could be appointed
under uh V on page two line 27. uh could
be appointed by the governor to this
Council that would certainly be
reasonable we also have the statement in
here of three mayors of their designees
and it doesn't say that it has to be a
mayor mayor of a major city uh except
for the smallest don't really have
Mayors never mind so that may not work
but I think we could get some of these
other experts in with the current
structure that is in the amendment that
thank you
anyone else wish to share ask anyone
okay seeing well I've seen one
representative snow
I'd just like to clarify my position I
was sounding terribly negative about it
and I guess in a lot of ways I am but
I'm also saying I think the new bill
with additional people is an improvement
over the previous bill which to me would
end up only talking about affordable
housing for people moving in for
business expansion here in New Hampshire
and would ignore all the people and even
among the homeless we have a big
difference between what happens in
cities like Manchester National perhaps
Portsmouth and some of the other largest
cities and Rural communities where you
have people doubled up living in
basements as he said in other places
even among those two restricted groups
there's very different problems that go
on this is a mammoth task I understand
that trying to get two commissions set
up and that's why I suggested if is
there any way of making sure that it's
understood that we didn't just add all
these additional people onto this
committee on housing stability
to
make it look more generic I'd like to
make sure that those people are at it
are really going to have the power and
the ability to address it and I know how
you go about doing that I don't pretend
to know
but I don't I think this bill well it's
an improvement is clearly going to leave
the the homeless population that
in a big disadvantage
representative snow
um May I make a parallel from work I do
with the deaf and hard of hearing we get
something in place that we thought we
would it would do something and it did
but it was it was good but it wasn't
what we had wanted so now I'm coming
back with a second try and and I think
we'll now wind up with two good things
so if it's the case going forward over
the next several months that it doesn't
seem that the Council on housing
stability really addresses what some of
us have been looking at the rural poor
and so on
um I've got several good folks can work
yes that's I guess that's the best we
can do I think I did I think so that's
what I had to face representative Nelson
that's true
hand down
that's true representative Marsh uh yes
thank you Mr chair uh I wanted to point
out the people that this amendment does
not just yet and people should be
existing Council and also expands upon
[Music]
homelessness
so I think that clearly we will be
directing the council to pay more
attention to the homelessness then they
are doing at this point in time which I
oh okay
I was I was really going to say the same
thing that representative Marsh just
said it does
um it does add the charge from
representative Longs bill as well as
adding
um all the extra people
um how long does it take once again it's
far from ideal because it's a lot of
people and it's a lot of tasks but
um it is inclusive of the tasks and
membership from the original bill yeah
[Music]
anyone else
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman I just have a
question do you think
um that any of these
members any of these Representatives who
will be on this board
um will be coming to the table and
bringing the principles of uh perhaps
reducing
um regulations to allow the free market
to help meet the needs of the homeless
to help with housing stability Etc
foreign
[Music]
can you repeat the question
so I'm seeing
yeah sorry I'm seeing um you know all of
these bureaus and groups and my instinct
is telling me that what will come out of
this is some
first of all it's a very large board
um or commission
um
so sorry
I see I foresee that there's going to be
some recommendations for you know
centralized control policy
um
it's probably similar to the governor's
Workforce housing policy that he wanted
to put into place uh and I was just
wondering if any of these
um
designees or executive directors or
Commissioners if any of these positions
do you see them coming at this with some
suggestions for how the free market
or reducing current regulations on safe
zoning or building
to deal with housing instability
do you see any of these members bringing
that kind of information to the table
thank you
um
I have not I had not thought about it I
had not thought about it in that way
there is a it does call from a
representative from the business
community
um
and there are well there are in the
I'm looking through this as I'm talking
to you
um
there is one specific particular
representative from the business
Community with an interest in affordable
housing
um I don't know if that point of view
would be to what extent that point of
view would be
um represented
anyone else
representative Weber
thank you um
um unfortunately representative snow oh
yes he's behind the the piece of paper
uh I have three things one is a point of
just how the committee Works
um it appears to me and I will ask this
through the chair it appears to me that
when representative snow is muted we do
not get the voice in the background uh
so I I am wondering if the chair would
ask representative snow to mute himself
when he is not speaking because we're
getting this is a follow-up to what
representative McKay said we're getting
a huge amount of somebody else's voice
and when you're muted we don't hear it
but or I don't hear it but when you're
not muted uh there is a noise coming in
the background so most of us mute our
computers when we're not directly
speaking and that helps thank you so
that's I'm number one item number two to
respond to representative Cushman uh I
see as members of the original uh group
uh somebody from the Department of
Business and economic Affairs and they
may or may not have an interest in free
market economics depending on who
appointed them and what their background
is but I also see a representative of
the landlords Association a
representative of the New Hampshire
Builders Association
um local providers of Housing Services
so and a County Economic Development
Council so it seems to me that there
isn't a minimum and opportunity for
those voices to be heard although not
being in charge of appointing them I I
can't make any promises but I think I
think that there is a fair amount of
thank you representative gay
well I've come up with the sort of sort
of a proposal one is that we pass the
amendment
oh with all this humongous group of
people
and that we make the suggestion to the
people who are boots on the ground
but they form their own
committee
so that they can come up with the
request things that they need money for
things that they need approval for
and present them it can be people who
are on this you know who are proposed to
be on this list on this committee but
they can meet separately whether they're
ordained to meet separately or which
they just do on their own but then they
come back to this truth and say this is
what we need
and so that then they have a big group
of people who can advocate for them I am
very concerned that if that doesn't
happen when you have the commissioner of
this and the head of this and the
director of this
I don't think that's going to be real
effective they can vote on things but I
don't think they're going to really be
directing the actual boots on the ground
work but maybe if they were a clearing
house and an approval and an advocacy
group then they might really lend their
weight to making some things happen
foreign
representative snow go ahead yeah I I do
want to apologize unfortunately I do
believe I was at fault for that my wife
had to take a phone call in a room down
the hall and I she was trying to be very
quiet but we're not successfully but
I'll be very conscientious about muting
when we can't this is a small apartment
so uh but I'll be more careful in the
future and secondly what I said when I
was talking was very much the same as
what uh representative it was a Cushman
that just spoke that's what I was
thinking if we could get this committee
to operate the way Finance does into
divisions where they work in divisions
but then they have to come together as a
whole committee to make their
recommendations and there'd be some
agreement that both sides would be
represented in the final recommendations
that would seem to work better I don't
know whether you have to put that in the
bill it does seem to me looking at the
list that there's enough strong-minded
people who of the group with boots on
the ground that they're going to exist
in this anyway Pat long doesn't sit
quietly for anyone so I think he there's
no concern about that but and I think on
the other side we have a lot of
high-ranking officials
that are on the other side so I think
the more I think about this it would
work but I think we need to try to
move people in the direction of seeing
it as being two separate subcommittees
that then come together and operate we
did that with this committee last year
Jim McKay and I added up a separate
group of mental health substance abuse
in marijuana and the other the remaining
members did together and then we all
came together in executive session to
finalize it and I think that worked out
reasonably well and if we could get this
group to operate in very much the same
way I think we have a better chance of
not leaving the homeless
way behind sorry and
um if you could uh mute please and now
representative knurk
thank you very much um I'd just like to
point out that on page 3 line 10 it says
the council may form subcommittees as
necessary in the course of its work so
that uh ability is there to develop a
subcommittee who might very explicitly
work on the homelessness questions
separately and I would think that would
be likely and and also in response to
representative cushman's comment one of
the other things she commented on was
zoning and a lot of the homeless
organizations uh particularly the New
Hampshire Coalition and homelessness
they also have often um addressed the
question of zoning and it's and then
particularly the over 55 restrictions
and you know large lot restrictions on
how that interferes with housing
availability which trickles down to
interfere with uh to cause homelessness
so I think that would be addressed as
well on this Commission thank you
anyone else if you're representative
Shapiro
yes I think there's a lot of
um understandably there's a lot of angst
about whether this um idea of combining
these two things will actually work or
not and I understand that I think that
that's um understandable I share that
um on the other hand
today we only have the power of passing
this bill as amended or not passing it
as amended unless we're going to recess
and get in another amendment so I think
another
possibility is those people who really
are concerned about this being too many
members or not focused enough on
homelessness make it their business to
be in touch with people who serve on
this Council
um and come back in uh in a year if
there are real problems with
um a new bill that would solve those
problems
but for today I think we can only pass
I'm in the middle of a middle to
upstairs that I have to finish up right
now
um
so hang in there for a second
[Music]
yeah
with no more hands the um motion before
us
is ought to pass
with Amendment zero six three four
zero six seven seven eight zeros all
right there it is zero six seven eight h
ate moved by representative Marsh and
seconded by representative King the
motion is fought to pass with the clerk
please call the roll
to chairman
representative Marsh yes representative
McMahon yes representative Nelson yes
representative Acton yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman
sorry which smoke just tell them to pass
with Amendment okay um
representative Folsom yes representative
Alexander yes
representative King yes Representative
kofault no
representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative snow yes
representative knurk yes representative
Solway yes representative Cannon yes
representative yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Pearson
yes 19 to 2. and representative Marsh if
you would write the committee reports
and between representative co-fulton
Cushman who would like to write a
minority court if any
I will be happy to do that thank you
representative kofolt writes Minority
Report
goes on the regular calendar
representative Cushman can you go out in
the hall and look for that Amendment
we've been discussing thank you
okay
yeah
um
may I ask what amendment we're talking
about is there something we're supposed
to be looking for in our email as well
um yeah eventually eventually
uh
eventually not right immediately we need
an amendment
six
I'm reading it is 676. yes you're six
zero six seven six of today should have
gone out to you by email I just don't
have a hard copy of it and I've received
it I just have a hard copy of it well
which Bill what
bills
let me answer 601
and we're not dealing with it next but
that's Jericho got it
so for future that's what it is I've got
it okay let's let's talk about a five
minute stretch break
and uh that oh by the way that is
um
[Music]
503. thank you we'll check the five
minutes stretch and bathroom break and
during the interval uh we can look for
Amendment zero six seven six our house
bill
601. Mr chair am I correct in thinking
that we have left
three bills left to exec is that correct
how could you number them for me because
I have I believe 295 which is the birth
record still 601 which is the uh privacy
of personal information Bill and that's
the one with the the um Amendment you
just referenced and 605 which is the
cannabis bill is that correct
um
okay it is I'll do them in numerical
order
290 uh which is the uh required for
health facilities and special Health
Care licenses we did that that was
amazing for the house session oh never
mind sorry
um
what about 492
never mind anymore
well well no this is the time to do it
it's called being gone for the week and
trying to come back and find all the
yes
so if we've got a few minutes
and I would take this moment to thank
the clerk again for all of her work yeah
yes yes
and
um it it really is admirable the job
you're doing we appreciate it yes but
the chair has quite a job
proofreading all my stuff
I had to read it I had to read a copy of
the Chairman's speech this morning that
was not my original my original had
unsplit infinitives where there were
split infinitives in the original I had
to do it that's why I was a stumbled and
throat and so I will try to go back to
the more edited version next time other
people don't know what a split is
benefits okay we should form a study
group on dangling participles but
infinitives and proper reference and
representative Weber I just I'm sure
you're thinking of your third and fifth
grade teacher I I am indeed but I will
decline to be on that committee because
as you all know my ability to proofread
particularly my own stuff is not good
so
well
I was very grateful in a couple of the
books I wrote 20 years ago that
I had is my external editor from the
Publishing House a husband and wife team
who would ghost written almost 100 books
and anything I learned about writing I
learned from them
I highly recommend
um
um EB White's uh essay about William
strunk's
elements of style
but the the Y EB white essay about omit
needless words and then because he had
omitted the needless words he said
everything three times so in class he
would go in and say omit needless words
um the worst kinds of redundancy is
[Music]
it's a redundant tautology
and representative Nutter Robin can
actually locate the books in their
a rabbi friend of mine his favorite joke
is what's another word for a thesaurus
[Music]
I thought it was hilarious
a thesaurus being the book of other
words for words
okay tough crowd here tonight oh yeah
yeah
thank you
and are you here all week yeah I'm
starts
yes
representative soloway how is Sophie I
haven't heard Sophie today
um Sophie was remanded to the exterior
of the house so that she she takes great
offense at my being in these conference
calls
um
feels that we uh are not paying
attention to her by the way if any uh
may I make a comment Mr chairman I'll be
back in session
no uh for those of you who care to
access
um out of sight out of mind the book by
uh Yvonne missing several things
um it did win the National Coalition on
homelessness
um book of the Year award it's very good
reading and the documentary that she
made was featured as the social action
theme of the Ben Jerry's one heart one
world group hug love dove uh folk music
festival in Stowe Vermont
um it's uh she really has done an
extraordinary amount of work and as you
read the book and you read the preface
you will find that it is dedicated to me
wow and speaking of would you tell the
assembled multitude why we could refer
to you as Louie
today
ah
I'm I'm amazed that you know that uh
yesterday uh we had a play reading uh
here in Portsmouth at our synagogue and
I played the part of Louis the uh
gangster in Neil Simon's play uh lost in
Yonkers and it was it's great fun and
Jennifer uh my beloved uh was Gert who
spoke only on the inhale not on the
exhale and we had a lot of fun doing it
breathtaking
you may call me Louie from now on we
should do this at our committee picnic
this summer and Mr chairman I think you
are already aware of this but in
addition to the medical community
represented on this committee are you
aware that there is a Tufts alumni
delegation Buffs
Puffs go jumbos who are they besides
yourself
um representative Weber and
representative McKay
go jumbos
speak to you guys every year in football
until we came into the New Millennium
and now uh Williams is scared of toss
football
okay we're coming we're coming back
opening the house
um executive session on House Bill 295
relative to initiating amendments and
corrections to birth records and
representative Cannon this is your bill
I have it somewhere in my file is like
I'd like to do you have a friend here
I've brought uh bring house amendment
number zero six zero eight h
for house bill 295.
the amendment
say the number again please
it's zero six zero eight h
the pressure speaks to it
and before we go further uh and while
they're looking forward you need to make
a motion on the amendment please
um I I move that we approve
Amendment
zero eight zero six zero eight h
uh is there a second second
okay I I it was marching it was Merchant
okay now
um please address your Amendment
[Music]
um
following up on this on the bill in our
discussion one of the pieces I added
it's a paragraph F which is on the
bottom of the amendment which was to
charge the secretary of state with
creating the form that's needed to
to go along with the application
for gender change on the birth record
um the one that's been overdue since
2005 to essentially Define the process
and the information required to make it
reality
um
I I have also based based on
conversations with others
I have changed the requirement
for
when the information is submitted to the
clerk's office
that it should be sent to the Vital
Records Office and
and then the original birth certificate
shall be retained in its original form
and a copy will be issued without a
marginal note
um and that's for a couple of reasons
first off one of the reasons that
individual comes forward to request a
new birth certificate is to not be
called out for having
a sex or gender change
and to put it in a marginal note is
pulling it out and by doing so we might
actually be in the situation where that
person is being discriminated against by
providing that information
or providing that information in a
printed form on their birth certificate
so I have changed
um
let's see
part of the sentence indicating that the
record has been amended in accordance
with this paragraph essentially it's to
the new birth record
then the birth record shall reflect the
Please be aware this is really doesn't
change
the original Statue What's Done in the
original Statue
in RSA
5-c colon 87 comma Roman Nero five
because this is what we actually do
there is no marginal note
on the on
birth record that's issued then there
will not be a marginal note on the one
that's issued now the Secretary of
State's Vital Records Office told me
that this is what needed to be added to
the paragraph to be consistent with the
current statute
and and that the um the original record
birth record that people have been
concerned about will be retained in its
original format
and that um instead of trying to figure
out which multiple groups could produce
an application for this we're just gonna
toss it over to the Secretary of State's
office and said you have the
responsibility to do this
um I I I did go out to the Secretary of
State's website and they don't have any
information about being able to change
the record but the statute still does
are you uh do you have some more are you
ready for some questions that's it
representative
snow
fine
you're unmuted
thank you oh you just needed it
thank you
I think representative snow is um
is
um
just has his hand up from before is that
I likewise must have had my hand up from
something previous
uh okay Mr chairman do we need a second
for the amendment
yes we did
we have it already is that correct
that's correct representative Canon move
representative Merchant seconded the
chair and up calls representative
Alexander
um thank you Mr chair and my question is
for the um Frank sponsor of the bill
um I know it's just the amendment by yes
my confusion is
um the analysis of the bill talks about
the uh the procedure to change
um to reflect a sex designation at Birth
but then the entire text the bill talks
about the gender designation change and
I want to know if you could help me
um distinguish
um the difference between the two and
um if there needs to be like you know
the change in something from OLS thank
you
um
I understand that there's references to
gender in the in the document
um where many of us are familiar with
gender versus sex however
on the document that's produced the
birth record includes sex it doesn't
identify gender we have the same issue
actually when we worked on the driver's
licenses the bill was was
identified as gender but the uh the
drivers uh the DMV prints out sex on our
driver's licenses so that's what it is
in this case it is sex that's actually
printed on the birth certificate
um although many of us identify with
gender so it's it's written in this as
gender but it's it is sex on the actual
form
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman I'm just going to speak briefly
to the amendment I
I support the bill but I can't support
this amendment simply for the fact that
I think that the birth certificate needs
to have a notation on it indicating that
it's been amended
um not just the original that's with the
the town clerk I think that it needs to
be
acknowledged so that when
procuring your birth certificate to
whatever organization is asking for it
they can see that it's been changed so I
can't support the amendment and if it
passes I won't be able to support the
bill representative yeah
I speak in our position because I think
that it's correct to
um well let's see I apologize for not
being a very good speaker I'm better at
writing because you can delete things
the issue here that's in that's in the
room that nobody say is that there's a
trans girls
who have retained their uh
male
Advantage physical Advantage for
participating in girls Sports
this is a very complicated issue that
needs to be addressed separately because
some trans girls you can look at and you
would never ever guess that they have or
trans and others that we've seen on TV
who are excellent athletes really dudes
look like boys and that's probably a
medical thing about the treatment when
it was done or if it's been done to so
yes I think that is an issue
but in this case most people are not
trans girls trying to participate in
sports that needs to be addressed but in
this case I think it's important enough
that the original birth certificate is
uh is kept on record along with the new
one
uh and that everybody has a right to
their privacy when they need
um to show a birth certificate for any
number of reasons the few times in your
life you really need it I don't think
it's anybody else's business what you
have gone through to change your sex
it's not something casually done it
takes years and it's it's just a really
not only expensive but expensive in
money but it's expensive in feelings and
time and attorneys and it goes upon and
on and on so I think that it's extremely
important to allow people who are trans
who have completed it
just like to get a driver's license they
ought to have a birth certificate that
doesn't give away their private medical
history to any stranger that they have
see no more hands up
but as before us is amendment
0608h to House Bill 295 moved by
representative Cannon and seconded by
representative Merchant and before the
clerk is asked to call the roll I'm
going to vote Yes on the amendment
because I believe as a general principle
the sponsor of a bill should be able to
present exactly the bill he or she wants
so I believe that irrespective of what I
believe in the amended bill I believe it
is the sponsor's right to have exactly
the bill the person wants so therefore
for that reason I'm going to
honor representative Canon and give the
amendment a yes vote
will the clerk call the roll please
thank you
representative Marsh yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson
no
representative Acton
representative gay
yes
representative Cushman now
representative Olson know representative
Alexander yes
representative King
no
representative copault
yes
representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk
representative Solway yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
representative Canon do you have a
Beauty Gary representative um
this is Christina um I moved I need to
be on camera
in order to have our votes count per the
speaker so if you are in the executive
voting mode you need to be seen on on
the screen
please
are we all set to vote I mean also
representative active
uh no I can okay thank you
representative Cannon you are recognized
for a motion
yes I move out to pass on House Bill 295
as amended with Amendment zero six zero
eight h
seconded by representative Weber is it
yes
I want to remind people with this bill
this bill doesn't change the intentions
of the RSA that already exists and has
existence existed since 2005 and that
RSA was RSA 5-c 87 Roman numeral five
um this this bill adds a process that
didn't exist back back then and hasn't
existed for 15 years it costs the state
and our
jurisdictions money to implement it
currently this will reduce the burden
and the cost associated with processing
these birth record updates
um
that that RSA has already determined
that
sex changes can be
recorded on a birth record in New
Hampshire it doesn't change that
it does provide for a form
to be used in the process to simplify
that process for the clerks and the
Vital Records Office as well as the
individual
thank you
what else representative Cushman thank
you Mr chairman
um representative Cannon just a point of
clarification so yes I understand that
it is legal to change birth certificates
to reflect a change of gender but am I
correct in my understanding that that
requires currently a court process and a
judge ordering that change
it it does and it requires a physician
make the decision that a judge makes the
Judgment upon the this this bill
requires a physician to sign the form
and have it
um
have it uh
annotated that that they are in fact uh
signing it themselves and it would be
thank you if it was somebody else also
[Music]
um
my feelings about birth certificates are
is that they should stay the way they
are
um
and it doesn't matter what the change is
so this has nothing to do with why this
bill particular bill has come forward I
just believe that any change in a birth
certificate should have a notation on
the birth certificate that a change has
anyone else
Mr chairman
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chairman I also want to point out with
the amendment
by having the Secretary of State create
a standardized form to be utilized
across the state it minimizes the issue
of city clerks or courts themselves and
have multiple types of forms in the
vital records so I think having a
standardized form across the state is
important and I also want to stress what
sent uh representative Canon said
it doesn't change
the process it doesn't change the law it
only provides a vehicle to a little lock
and go forward this has been around
since 2006 and sadly we have to actually
have an amendment or a statute to uh
create an application process that
should have been done probably 14 years
ago
I see no more hands up that's more
first
rubber Merchant snow and Shapiro
representative whoever sounds like a law
firm
well I'm very glad that I got to be
senior partner but um it's
let me say it's a disadvantage to have
your Law Firm start with a name with a W
so uh always get the one who's first in
the alphabet uh I just wanted to point
out and I thank representative Cannon
for her changes on this but we do
actually amend birth certificates for
all kinds of reasons
um uh you can you can amend them
um generally speaking I'm not sure that
this is the case in New Hampshire but it
certainly was in the case in Vermont you
have a grace period of a couple of years
to amend the name on a birth certificate
we issue new birth certificates when a
child is adopted
there are other reasons and I they don't
come immediately to my mind but you do
we do change birth certificates I think
that it is very important that we retain
the original record and this bill has
done that but I also think that the
whole purpose
of
what we issue and this is the way we do
it now is that the individual get a new
birth certificate that they can hand to
somebody else uh that does not have a
marginal note on it that affirms who
they are and and is again you know this
is not done lightly or easily even
though we have the only thing we're
doing here is taking the court process
out of it thus saving money and time
both for the individual involved and for
our overburdened court system uh it's
it's a thing that's better done with
medical personnel and the people who
keep the records so thank you I'm
supporting it
I gotta take my hand down sorry for that
sorry I forgot to remove my
last time no questions
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you representative Cannon
am I correct to think that as well as
reducing the burden on courts that this
bill
um when passed and signed will
create more consistency for people who
want to make this change in their birth
record
um that when people go to the courts to
do that that different judges might use
different criteria to decide what
constitutes a change in sex
um for example whether there needs to be
surgery or not but this will create a
situation where there is consistency
across the board that people can ask
their health care provider
that's correct representative
um
currently our courts are given different
information from different Physicians
and different applications there is no
consistency even the clerk's offices are
handed handwritten letters or typed
letters or whatever but it's all
different information in all different
forms and formats this what this bill
would standardize the information that's
provided so that the Vital Records
Office will get the information they
need and the local towns or cities will
get the information they need to keep a
standard record in format
I do want to say that the
currently
people do this they have been doing this
for 15 years
the
the information is widely varied that's
gone to different courts and courts may
have two or three times that they have
to bring the applicant and their medical
professionals in to educate the court on
how to make a decision on this
uh so the court becomes
completely dependent on the medical
professionals that have been working
um
they will continue to use this very
confusing process
it won't change what we're currently
doing people will still continue to get
their birth record changed
without a marginal note on their birth
certificate so this bill doesn't change
that it does simplify the process and it
representative knurk thank you very much
uh yes I and I think that it is
appropriate to get the courts out of
some perception which
to me is a very strong reality
but still perception laid parallel
with
hard cold facts
um
the birth certificate has
the wrong area of the country
that has information that may impact
diseases that are of more much more in
one place than another the data gets a
little off
or representative Nelson's comment about
[Music]
um
I'm 71 because I showed up in June of
1949 irrespective of how I feel like I'm
an extremely young 71 and I want
everybody to know it
I'm thinking of Alexander Hamilton who
really wanted to be president but he
could not be president because he was
born in Saint Kitts and Nevis
and if he said look I've been here in
America for a long time I feel more
American than you know Uncle Sam and
anybody else you want to mention I
really really feel myself to be an
American the fact is he was born in
Saint Kitts and Nevis
and know his birth certificate shouldn't
be changed or how about the woman who's
so identified with black folks and loved
them and loved that culture and so on
and did various things and took various
things and and passed for black and
became head of an NAACP chapter
until it was learned she was white
and you know uh
wonderful to identify with her black
community and and whatnot you know
cultural approach appropriation be
damned she was happy to do that but the
fact of the matter is she was not black
and so for me
documents that would say here is how I
perceive myself to be here is what I
wish people to know me as people call me
as and all of that rock on but
chromosomes were there at Birth
and
if there is a document that
is the I really believe myself to be
documented
now becomes the birth certificate
when a person goes to a coach
of a girl sports team and say I want to
play on this team
and there's only 14 people on the team
and not one of them is going to be
bounced from the team and what is the
proof that you should play on this team
here's my birth certificate it
unequivocally says I'm female
and now somebody's been bombed
um
you know in terms of
celebrating
who One Believes oneself to be
you know yeah absolutely but in terms of
documents that
not only are supposed to be objective
but are used to prove
your age
I'm over this age now
I I really want to get Medicare
or any other
use
no to me that's not right
so I will not be supporting the bill
I understand discomfort with certain
changes enumerated by several people who
have spoken
but that's not the bill that's in front
of us
the bill that's in front of us
simply
makes easier a process which has already
been the law in this state for 15 years
that's all it does
you can already do everything in this
bill by going in front of a judge
so
you can't change your age you cannot
change your race you cannot change the
fact that you were born in Nevis
um you can only change this one thing
and with the amount of effort and pain
and personal journey and medical
interventions that go along with
changing
one's birth
gender to one's real gender
the idea that somebody would go through
that for the privilege of being able to
play on a girls sports team thereby
bumping a girl with female chromosomes
rather than a playing on a boy's team
where they might not make the theme is
just ridiculous the issues here are so
much more complicated than that and the
process is so much more complicated and
so much more difficult but I can't
imagine that anybody would go through it
unless they had that voice inside of
them saying
I'm not a girl I'm a boy or I'm not a
boy I'm a girl
so for that reason this is only changing
an administrative procedure it's not
changing anything else and
um I urge people to vote for it
thank you representative Cannon
my health history
in
in all of my records with my health care
flags that I am a transgender individual
male to female
those records go with me wherever I go
as far as an individual
so people from a health care perspective
know exactly who I am and what changes
have been done to my body
um
I
my birth certificate exists down in
Newton Massachusetts I have a new birth
certificate that indicates my new name
as well as
I haven't had the chance to have to use
that birth certificate for anything
except for updating information on my
social security card
and my
uh
passport
and even in the case of the passport I
had to provide a doctor statement that I
I did change information on insurance
policies there were no questions asked
they just asked except for a copy of my
revised birth certificate
and name change
and they just took it as this is the way
it is and they updated the information
there was no question
for me as an individual and my own
Mental Health
it was
something that needed to happen in my
life
this didn't happen until I didn't have
change my information until five years
ago
I'm 68 years old now
a lot of people go through this process
and fight all their lives and that was
an affirming thing for me
I will probably never use my birth
certificate again it will sit in the
drawer or put it and it will stay on
file with the city of Newton in
Massachusetts
in case I ever need it
thank you
thank you representative Shapiro
um I completely understand people's
discomfort with changing a birth
certificate that
um just doesn't seem logical
um and for logical people like me it
kind of
sticks in my craw and likewise recently
in the last couple of years somebody in
my extended family
um asked all of us to start calling them
by a different pronoun by they them
and it was incredibly difficult for me
um at first I could do it maybe one in
ten times
over the last couple of years I've
gotten better I can do it maybe
seventy percent of the time but I often
get it wrong and somehow it makes me
uncomfortable in terms of just my
you know the grammar that I learned my
whole life it just doesn't make sense to
me
but
I thought about this a lot and I can
compare my discomfort
um
with something that seems
off grammatically to me I can't compare
my comfort to the healing
um that this means to somebody and I
can't really I could never really
um articulate it better than
representative Cannon just articulated
so I'm very willing to have my
discomfort with these things so that
people who are
um who struggled their whole lives and
come to grips with who they really are
and have the courage to make changes out
in the world
um to feel more like themselves I can't
compare my discomfort with a birth
certificate or with trying to get the
grammar right
um
I'm the one that has to get over it and
um it's well worth getting over it so I
will vote Yes for this
representative Nelson didn't take the
hand down I guess
representative guy
I think uh this is kind of like a
compromise
because if you're like me you thought
you thought that in the past in the past
15 years you thought that the original
birth certificate was retained
it turns out there were two paths uh
representative Cannon I'll have to
explain if you want to know but there
were two paths to get your birth
certificate changed and one of them when
the judge did it your original birth
certificate was destroyed
so this is the step for everybody who
really wants records kept this is a step
in the right direction to retain the
original to keep the history
so that does not
this this bill does not deal with the
issue of
how how much is someone's sex change
when they're a kid in high school should
should trans boys trans girls get to
play that's that affects some people and
it is an issue but it's not this one
and that if you really want the records
to be right
this bill makes them more correct than
see nothing further the chair calls on
himself for a motion and the motion is
if the motion is ought to pass as
amended made by the chair apologizes for
the motion on the floor is on a past is
amended as moved by representative
Cannon and seconded by representative
Weber House Bill 295 with the amendment
0-608h and the clerk may call the roll
thank you Mr chairman representative
Marsh
no
representative McMahon no representative
now
representative Cushman no representative
gay yes
representative Folsom no representative
Alexander no
representative co-fault
no representative King no
yes
representative McKay yes representative
snow yes representative knurk yes
yes that was a yes
oh look thank you representative Cannon
yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes
yes sure
oh sorry representative Pearson no
11 10 it passes
the bill passes 11 to 10 representative
Cannon would you like to write the
report okay we'll do that all right
thank you
and this concludes
I will do the Minority Report this
concludes the hearing on House Bill 295.
excuse me this concludes
and so we can get done while we're young
the
chair
opens the
and
there were a number of amendments from
representative
um
amen that he has withdrawn
in favor of the only amendment he wishes
to consider which is amendment zero six
seven six
h
and would somebody choose to move that
Amendment
representative Cushman you would choose
uh and representative cofult
okay please speak to the amendments
Okay so
thank you Mr chairman this
um Amendment a little background on the
bill the Department of Health and Human
Services without legislative input and
without executive Council approval
entered into a contract under the
emergency orders to develop a closed
food referral system this closed loop
referral system will be created to
enhance Coordinated Care for New
Hampshire residents seeking Social
Services by creating a single database
of recipients that can be searched by a
network of providers and the goal is to
treat the whole person
in Seeking a vendor for the sole source
contract the Departments the department
sought a solution to reduce the number
of informed consent forms needed to
connect clients with services in an
effective manner
the amendment
um
puts a pause on this system
um so it will not be able to be used on
the general public as I understand it
the protection
of personal private information is
critical of critical importance to New
Hampshire citizen citizens and um
um basically says it shall not be put
into operation for members of the
general public before July 1st 2022 this
will give the legislature
um a chance to look into the system and
um you know make some decisions on
on it and if it needs work before it can
be
broadly applied before I call on
representative Marsh I hope everybody
got the letter from house counsel James
cnc's CNC relative to this and uh some
of us from both parties raised a
question of constitutionality with uh
House Council CNC does not make a final
ruling but agrees that there's there
could well be some difficulty with this
representative Marshalls
thank you
I I'm uh of the understanding because of
communications between myself and the
Department of Health and Human Services
and because I personally reviewed the
contract which I downloaded from the
executive Council website that in fact
this data sharing rolled out and became
effective in December 2020. I personally
believe that it is a constitutional to
pass drug laws and while I totally
support the idea of the privacy and I do
feel the department could have done a
better job of protecting for our state I
don't believe it's the purview of this
legislature the password and therefore I
unfortunately will have to vote against
anyone else yes please
and the chair calls on the person who
said yes please
yes please person was representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you
um and
um I agree
I agree with everything well almost
everything that everybody said I'm very
concerned about this process and how
it's rolling out and I do think we ought
to look into it more and that is
something that both this committee could
do either by creating an ad hoc
committee to look into it or some
members of the committee less than a
majority could look into it entirely on
their own or we could refer it to the
Health and Human Services oversight
committee and I think all of those
things should be done but I
um agree with representative Marsh that
I am concerned enough about interference
with contract that although I agree with
the sentiment in the amendment and I
think it is a better way of going than
the original bill I cannot vote for this
amendment and I cannot vote for the bill
so thank you very much
thank you representative anyone else
representative gay
I'm
intrigued by
um the offering that there could be a
meeting of times to discuss it
is there any action that could be taken
post passing this bill are not
representative Cushman
my understanding is that mission to
protect people's
um
medical history just by some tests the
whole state past the um
the Privacy at addendum to our
constitution
there's going to be a change let let it
come out but not not us just say oh it's
fine it's okay we can't do anything so I
would definitely support this amendment
representative
[Music]
thank you Mr chairman so I I support the
amendment and I support the bill and
um yeah I I thank representative Cushman
for pointing out the fact that this was
not
a contract that was approved by the
council
um my concern is that there is not
uh there there really has not been any
legislative oversight for this contract
I'm concerned that you know we have a
duty to to protect the privacy
um in the security of information of of
New Hampshire residence information and
you know a lot of the people who are
served by social service agencies are uh
you know may not may not necessarily be
understanding what they're signing
um
who are understanding what they're
opting into so
um as it is right now if I go into the
doctor's office they're going to ask me
to sign a form
um and that's going to be pretty
specific as to
who and for you know what information
can be shared or who it can be shared
with and when
um and my concern is that under this
closed-loop referral system there is
kind of a wide open door in fact
additional agencies could join I could
be sharing my information sort of on a
blanket basis
um
with lots and lots of agencies sort of
whoever whoever comes uh in into the
closed-loop system in the future and in
that respect it's kind of a blank check
so you know if if somebody who is
dealing with a substance abuse problem
uh comes in for help and is you know is
is uh
essentially giving you know giving
consent to
to have their name entered into this
closed or Loop referral system it seems
to me that we're we're asking them to to
to sign a blank check so to speak and I
I think that's a dangerous precedent for
us to be setting the concern I have is
that there needs to be legislative
oversight so if something like
it fails so the amendment fails 15 to 5.
now we go to the original bill which the
amendment was to replace all other
amendments have been withdrawn
would uh representative Marsh have a
the reports of somebody else wants to
make a motions
where somebody else I don't see anybody
else making a thank you representative
representative representative web or
emotion
um I would move itl on the bill
um I don't think we need to discuss it a
lot I I think the concerns that we have
are present in the original Bill only
more so so
um it interferes with contract and I
think that that's a bad place for us to
be going so
um
that's really all I have to say about it
thank you
the motion before us is House Bill 601
FM
in its original form
moved it out by representative Weber
seconded by representative Marsh
with the clerk please call the roll
thank you Mr chairman representative
Marsh yes
representative McMahon yes
yes representative Nelson yes
representative act in
absence
representative gay
yes no no sorry no
representative Cushman no
representative Folsom no representative
Senate Alexander Smith
representative Cobalt no
representative Weber
yes representative McKay
yes
representative Solway yes
representative Canon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant yes
yes
[Music]
so it was fourteen to five fourteen to
five yes and this one was also 14 to 5
in favor
of Ito and our previous one was fourteen
I thought it was thank you and
representative we've already had two
absence
please send me
I will thank you very much and I am very
very merciful if you care or care not to
use the form that has been sent down
from on high that I can't figure out
myself
yes I I will do my best but I'm pretty
sure I track it
thank you as close as the hearing and
excuse this closes the executive session
on House Bill 601 and last
um before we could have a minority oh of
course thank you
minority reports who wishes to do The
I would I will do that and that is
representative kofalt thank you very
much
last unless you can find another one I
found one this morning good thing too
yeah
um we are now opening the consecutive
session on House Bill
we've got a plethora
multitude of amendments here that sends
information gives us a lot of latitude
we can take up all four of these
amendments
together
and they would be representative marshes
the second part had to do with visiting
qualifying patients
it's important to realize that I was
asked a question which I couldn't answer
the visiting patient access was not a
DHHS request however Michael Holt had
worked very hard on the language with
the sponsor last year uh which uh passed
our committee and the house
um there were also concerns raised about
this uh Proviso uh having to do with any
country and the question is how would we
know what a card looks like and so on
regard to verifying out of state cards
it is actually the therapeutic cannabis
program already has been dealing with
this
um they have they've shared their card
design with many other states and those
other states share it with ours for that
exact purpose many states allow this
kind of reciprocity some have formal
reciprocity agreements with other states
for that purpose others simply need just
simply share that card template with the
other state dispensaries
so the dispensaries can verify what an
out-of-state card looks like and that's
rather similar to sharing a state
license design state to a another state
to incur underage drinking
um the goal we we felt would be probably
reasonable for
um therapeutic cannabis program to
develop a nice simple system for the
atcs it might be like a little uh almost
like a scrapbook with the copy of the
cards from the various States and uh so
we added in rule making Authority for
them to do that
in addition it's important to realize
that the initial aspect of this Bill had
to do primarily with other States and
Canada and the reason is we border
Canada and just as we have many people
who come to our uh our state for an
extended period of time from either
Maine or Vermont or Massachusetts or
perhaps even other states either
students or people who have second homes
we do have a significant number of
Canadians who come here to stay for an
extended period of time again to realize
that if they are a qualifying patient in
their home jurisdiction
to wander across state lines with
cannabis is illegal to wander across
International boundaries is even more
illegal and so if you have a patient who
is a qualified patient in Canada and by
the way Canada has a nationwide program
not province-wide Nationwide so they
want to come down from Quebec and uh
stay at a place for a few weeks down in
New Hampshire and go hiking they don't
have to carry it they would be able to
uh have their get their cannabis here
that's the whole point of this so we
currently have in statute the authority
to allow other states other qualified
patients from other states to be able to
be protected in the same fashion as our
patients are protected meaning they
won't be arrested for possession this
just simply allows them to be able to
purchase so again please pull out zero
six four six because I'll use that as a
template to go over the aspects of the
amendment so you understand all the
details
um the first lines three
through eight uh has to do with the oud
and that's the one that just simply
makes it much more stringent we already
covered that
the next lines nine through 14.
what that does is it simply allows the
uh the ATC to be able to convey to a
visiting qualifying patient
lines 15 through 18 actually is a
Prohibition statement it is in the uh
it's in the statute where it says it
includes all except the following and
what it says here is that the
cultivation or purchase from a
qualifying patient or designated
caregiver is not covered in other words
you can purchase from an ATC but you
can't purchase from another qualified
patient or a designated caregiver in
this state so again that though that
looks like it's allowing it it's not
it's saying it is not covered by the
card
then if we go to lines 19 through 29
that is the part that allows the patient
uh who is a qualifying patient in
another jurisdiction to be able to
possess and again narrowed it from all
countries to only Canada
and then if we go to lines 30 uh for
sorry 30 to the second page
um that is the one that once again takes
away all countries goes to Canada only
and then there was a very interesting
thing which I found
um when doing a deep dive in this that
there was a drafting error that if we
look at
um lines page two lines nine through
eleven it actually had been worded
incorrectly and said you couldn't
purchase from the ATC we tidied that up
so now it just says that visiting
patient shall not cultivate
and they also cannot purchase from a
qualifying patient or designated
caregiver a redundancy was what was
there before but it does not say they
can't purchase from an ATC because that
was the whole point of this
and then the last one is the new uh
section which just gives the rules for
the cards so the idea is that the
therapeutic cannabis program will
develop a system for the atc's verifying
cards so that they're all using the same
method to do verification so basically
again six four six is the one that
includes both oud
and the visiting patient provides us
allowing them to purchase from an ATC
allows oud
only does not address the visiting
patient question
oh six four five addresses the visiting
patient only
does not include the oud question so
that way we can decide which one we want
to go with we can then vote on that and
not have to do a whole lot of time I had
the chair and I discussed perhaps doing
a quick straw vote because it seems like
everybody is pretty comfortable with
both then we could just move 0646 and
not have to go through Amendment after
it gets it more complicated because
representative Marsh in this amendathon
has zero four a two who would do
something quite different yet and
representative Marsh yes thank you Mr
chair in the event none of these
amendments are adopted before but I
believe I could support them at zero six
four five eight which allows out of
state cases from the United States and
Canada to utilize our atcs for the valid
process
um I don't believe I can support the
other two amendments because I think the
data hopefully a use disorder is full of
discipline and that there is at least
some data that would lead me to believe
that they actually made profiling use
may I actually speak to that for a
moment too I actually speak
okay yes and I the the board really does
agree with what representative Marsh
just said the whole point is that THC is
a gives reward therefore it will in
increase issues of
um use disorder it's the CBD which has
the ability to work on withdrawal and
the craving issue and that is why we set
up such tight guard rails so that you
have a person who is aware of that
because we were pretty convinced that
your average practitioner your average
PCP even a medication assisted treatment
PCP is not going to have enough
knowledge base to be able to make that
distinction because remember a provider
which in this case should be an
addiction psychiatrist or addiction
medicine specialist has the authority
and the ATC must follow it they have the
authority to request a CBD predominant
or CBD only preparation
um in other words it isn't that they
just go in the ATC decides what they
want they can request CBD only and that
must be followed
and this is the chair speaking
um remind me please you said there was a
drafting era that is not in Amendment
6458 correct no the the drafting error
was in the original bill
yeah and I we fixed that I just simply
found the inconsistency checked it with
Mike Holt he agreed there was that was
incorrect and we corrected that thank
you very much
um representative Shapiro
yes thank you Mr chairman
um representative canark
in Amendment zero six four six which
includes the opioid use disorder and the
visiting
um Canadians
um I'm concerned about the
um kind of strict guard rails or
guidance around who can qualify that
person and I wonder if um Michael Holt
has chimed in or whether he can chime in
right now about will that create
problems in administrating
um the atcs and following that strict
guidance if Mr Holt has been a meeting
um
uh hello uh thank you for the
opportunity my name is Michael Holt I'm
the administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program
um representative Shapiro can you repeat
your question are you concerned about
the atc's verifying out-of-state cards
or is your question about the
Department's ability to
um enforce the provider type guard rails
for the certification for oud
my concern is in regards to somebody
being qualified with an opioid use
disorder there's a lot of conditions
about who can be the qualifying
physician
excuse me products can be used and I'm
wondering if that's going to create
problems for the aatc in atcs in in
terms of being able to follow all those
different conditions
okay I understand thank you for the
questions but there's two elements here
the first is uh the Department's ability
to
um enforce the provider qualifications
um that's not an issue for us we would
establish those uh um documentation or
verification protocols so that we can be
assured that the provider is certifying
for oud are in fact board certified in
addictions Psychiatry or a medicine it's
not an issue for us at all
um regarding the second piece about the
atc's uh
um
enforcing or implementing a provider's
instruction on dispensing that's a
process that we already have in place
right now where providers can send
instructions to the ATC and then the ATC
um our atcs are required to follow those
instructions when they dispense to that
particular patient so that that was
that's something that we could uh that
we wouldn't have an issue with enforcing
either
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
Merchant
I
put my hand up you're always welcome
when you want to come back
representative Folsom
um I I think I'm agreeing with
um representative Marsh on this one I am
really happy that they made the changes
to just Canada I feel like big shots
that whole ID kind of program under
control as far as the medical marijuana
cards
um but I just don't feel comfortable
with the opioid right now
um I think that science uh the science
isn't totally there yet
um and that's due you know to the ball
fit nobody can do a lot of the research
yet
um until the federal government makes up
its mind what it's going to do but I'm
just not feeling comfortable with the
opioid but I would definitely feel
comfortable with the
um sharing of medical marijuana cards
from and purchasing from state to state
and with
um
the Cannabis protections
thank you anyone else
thank you Mr chairman
um I am
I I think with the guard rails which are
pretty steep guard rails I'm okay with
the opioid use disorder treatment
provision
um and I am very much in support of the
visiting patient Provisions with the
addition of of patients from Canada I
wonder if perhaps a way to proceed would
be to offer
uh six and if that's voted down then to
offer 45
uh because that way we would have the
the
we'd have both of both pass but if both
don't pass it's very clear which
direction I think we're the committee is
going in unless other people have
something to say if you'd prefer to do
it via straw poll I'm I'm glad to do
that too but I I think sounds to me like
those are the decisions we're making is
whether the the
um uh opioid use disorder treatment is
in or out
I'm leaning towards doing a hybrid of
both and that is a strong Paul uh just
kind of see where the room is because
the body language we can't do that so
easily here
um and and then do that descending order
of voting on amendments uh
representative Woods
uh thank you Mr chair
um uh I'm in favor of of both uh going
with I guess it's six
um in terms of the oud
I'm I'm very uh pleased to get the
result from the oversight committee
um uh knowing the people that are on
there and I know a lot of them
personally uh if this came out unanimous
uh knowing the the general flavor and
the strictness with which these
individuals and I said I know many of
them
um I'm very surprised
to say it unanimous support for oud
knowing these folks and the fact that it
did come out
as unanimous uh means that it passed
very stringent you know
standards uh so I have I I'm in favor of
of doing that and moving ahead with six
may I respond to representative Woods
for a moment yes you may yes and indeed
Molly Rossignol Ed and said and Savage
were both there and did vote for it and
uh yes you're you're so right sudden
totally opposed therapeutic cannabis in
the beginning and they are extremely
strict so that was uh that's why I was
amazed I didn't expect this outcome at
all thank you
I know they're both on there and the
fact that it was 9-0 means they had to
anybody else
let's see how we can wrestle this thing
um
by the way I think that representative
Weber's idea is pretty good if we if we
vote for the one with both and it passes
we're done if it doesn't I think she's
right oud seems to be the one people are
stuck on more so than the visiting
patient that we could then we would know
that it died because of oud so I'm
comfortable with either a straw poll or
just going to 646 and then six four five
six four six is you're comfortable with
opiates and Canadians
exits for five you're uncomfortable with
opioids but comfortable with Canadians
and all right I'm going to stop talking
now
um when somebody moves 646 amendments
representative
and second yeah oh you can't second it
you just moved it I seconded it Weber
representative Weber okay we have before
us Amendment
zero six four six h
to House Bill 605
FM
it was moved by representative knurk and
seconded by representative Weber and the
motion is to accept the amendment with
the clerk please
call the world thank you may we may we
clarify though for everybody this one
has both
oud
and visiting patients
thank you
representative Marsh no representative
McMahon yes
representative Nelson no
representative Acton yes
representative gay
no
representative Cushman yes
representative Folsom no
representative King no
representative co-fault yes
representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk
yes representative Solway yes
representative Cannon
yes
representative Nutter Upham also yes
representative Shapiro
thank you representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes
it's 14 to 6. 14 to 6 it passes
representative connectio now withdraw
zero six four five and zero six four
four
yes sir
representative Marsh I believe
representative
sorry yes uh may I make a motion then to
accept 605. no no no no I will not I
will not accept that just yet okay got
it
then we also have a parallel motion and
I'm going to ask my predecessor for some
wisdom here would it be possible to
accept both the uh Amendment we just
looked at and representative Marsha's
amendments and have uh OLS melt them
no
yeah you're muted
sorry I can't offer an opinion on that
because I can't remember what was in
representative Marsh's Amendment uh I
think that in the past and to be really
safe you'd need to check this with the
clerk
um
because I might be remembering from a
previous clerk
um when two amendments were not
conflicting with each other you could
adopt both
um and the uh OLS would produce a third
Amendment which combined the two
for ease of dealing with the calendar
because I think we only do one committee
Amendment for the calendar uh but I I
don't know what the subject of
Representative Marsh's amendment is
um if if representative Marsh wants to
offer his Amendment that's one thing but
we don't have to actually do anything
with Representatives Amendment unless he
chooses to offer it it just correct I
just wanted to see this
and may I speak to that too no I think
representative Marsha is going to speak
to his Amendment next right the the
issue in my amendment was the issue of
employees being protected for their
transported candidates between
Communications while they're on the job
and it's my understanding that that is
being addressed by another bill and so I
didn't feel confused to bring its goals
so the question is moot now
Representative no that was all I wanted
to say it's an SB 162 that the Senate
Omnibus Bill it's already in there so we
don't need 482 because it's covered in
the Senate Bill thank you now let's see
we've got this uh wonderful Amendment
here to House Bill 601
that is oh wait wait we haven't voted on
so we're up to an um
[Music]
on the bill
right
we passed the amendment but we haven't
passed the bill
yep that's correct
ly she's been fading fast uh
representative Marsh would you take the
chair please
yes thank you
at this point in time we're discussing
[Music]
about to pass uh that's amended by zero
six four six eight and representative
America recognize you to make that
function
yes indeed I want to move that hb605 be
ought to pass with Amendment zero six
four six h
uh
second thank you representative Pearson
Is there further discussion I see
they're expensive active
I just want to quickly uh thank
representative knurk for the uh amazing
work he's done on on pulling this bill
together uh good work
is there any further discussion on the
saying none of the chair will ask the
clerk to call the role
I'm sorry I was not paying close
attention uh who who was who moved it
representative moved and representative
whoever's second into the motion ought
to pass as amended with Amendment zero
six four six H thank you
thank you Mr acting chairman uh
representative Marsh
representative Marsh folks no
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson no
representative Acton yes
representative gay yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Folsom yes
representative King
yes
representative cofult yes
representative Weber
yes
representative McKay yes representative
snow yes
representative knurk s yes
representative Solway yes representative
Cannon yes representative Nutter Upham
yes representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant
representative Pearson
oh
[Music]
what percentage of whether the majority
uh
I'll take care of that I mean I've
already done the work on it
thank you I did not make promotion yeah
I made the motion and I've done the work
it's easier for me to do
so repeat again who is making the
majority report
Minority Report March
17-3 it passes as amendment I think
that's it
I want to thank first of all I want to
apologize to everybody I've been pulling
a migraine all day and oh I have been
more uh confused than ever I apologize
for that I hope I wasn't rude to anybody
and if I was I also apologize for that
uh we got it done folks this has been
great we're not going to have a lot
coming over from the uh the other people
and I'm hearing from the speaker's
office uh that we probably will have our
next big voting sessions in early April
so already uh start planning these odds
and and have a good time I have a
question
um are we meeting this Thursday no we're
done oh no I'm gonna have to work and
then there's sorry I'm sorry I have
another job
um and then I do but I won't go into
detail because everybody's tired and so
we are not having a big session in
whatever football stadium on March 28th
um it looks like the next session for
voting as a house will be in Bedford in
early April that isn't set in stone yet
but that's that's what it looks like uh
we are not meeting on Thursday Thursday
um House Bill 605 exact is
concluded and thank you very much
before you're before you go let me just
thank the chair
um it is an extraordinary accomplishment
to have gotten through all of these
bills in any case but doing it this way
is much more extraordinary and I just
wanted to thank you for your
um
kindness to all of us and your fairness
to all of us and I hope that your
migraine passes quickly but I just
didn't want to let that go without
saying thank you we appreciate it well I
wish to thank both my predecessor who
has been my parliamentarian without you
know without uh any comparison and also
to all of you it's it's been great
because we've all wanted it to be we've
all wanted to be fair and polite and we
disagree about things but we're not
disagreeable to each other so it's been
an honor I've chaired committees before
and this is my favorite so thank you too
thank you
working in the background running the
computers oh yeah
thank you Christina
great job
it's like the sheriff I'd like to share
a story about our esteemed chairman that
might improve his headache a little bit
three years ago when I was hospitalized
for an extended period of time
and my wife was informed that they had
to reserve the number of visitors that
came into my room and they so they put
you had to have a password in order to
get into the room and all the rest of it
and all of a sudden Mark suddenly
appeared in the room and I said oh did
you get the password no no no why would
a man in a clerical caller need a
password to get into a room at the
Catholic Medical Center and there's a
regular visitor to me while I was in
hospital and always Warriors clerical
call he does know how to get around the
tough nurses
didn't matter they don't make that
distinction no they don't look that
close but I believe the representative
snow said I'm not Catholic and I looked
at him and I said I'm not either and
then and after I get over being scared I
prayed with them and we were both quite
happy after that lo and behold he's back
so here we are yeah
Kevin Mark is a priest just an Anglican
priest yeah I know that and respect that
I I did not see it was an appropriate
time to get into a long historical
discussion with the
um people running CMC I walked in they
looked at me they said right this way
father I said thank you very much and
the rest is history
it was okay
to me I can tell you thank you
and with that
oh
yes